make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
DC fans my peeps I was sitting here
trying to figure out what story I was
gonna do for a classic DC story because
I'm not nearly as well-versed in classic
DC as I am with you know Marvel stories
before all-new all-different marvel and
so I figured if I'm going to do stories
before the new 52 then I've got to do
something big something that just pops
so I'm coming out boom boom guns blazing
we're doing crisis on Infinite Earths
now a little bit of exposition a little
bit of lead-up to this the so before
crisis on Infinite Earths DC's
continuity was an absolute mess not only
that
Batman's comics were on the verge of
cancellation because it just couldn't
get him to sell due to the restrictions
from the comics code Authority actually
have a video on that there were all
kinds of different things a really good
example is a Wonder Girl down at Roy's
so when Wonder Woman header publications
and she was wildly popular DC decided to
take the Superboy approach and what they
did is they wrote a series of stories
starring someone called Wonder Girl and
it was designed to be Wonder Woman when
she was younger and the various
adventures that she had the problem was
that whether it was through
miscommunication or a lack of concern
when the Teen Titans were launched DC
took the character of Wonder Girl and
they threw her on the Teen Titans and so
it created continuity problems because a
question fans had was how could he have
Wonder Woman as a girl and the stories
are supposed to be her in the past but
she's currently in the present and so
instead they rewrote her origin story
and so at that in conjunction with
things like Earth one earth two or three
where you had the evil Justice League
called the crime syndicate it created
all kinds of different issues fans
didn't know where to start in someone
1985 under the writing of Marv Wolfman
and the artistry of George Perez DC said
everything stops we're gonna reboot it
all we're gonna wipe the slate clean and
we're gonna start over and that was
crisis on Infinite Earths now the way
this starts the way this picks up is we
initially did this this short little
origin of the universe now there will be
a huge explanation that we'll get later
on so don't worry DC doesn't leave us
hanging with the origin of the DC
Universe keep in mind all this stuff is
before the new 52 years so this is all
original content with the first three
boo that they did but they basically
tell us you know of course in the
beginning there was nothing and then we
got the multiverse and there was an
infinite number of Earth's that came
into existence all of which were wild
different and they were totally changed
they have their own experiences and so
on now initially we pick up an earth 3
now for those of you guys who don't know
earth 3 is essentially the opposite of
virtually all as a earths that we saw
the main story's main universes on this
will be earth 1 earth 2 and R 3 R 3 is
the crime syndicate of America and the
evil version of the Justice League and
so instead of Wonder Woman you have
superwoman instead of the Green Lantern
and you have power ring instead of
Superman you have Ultraman and instead
of Batman you have our man but they are
basically villains they're bad guys the
superhero on Earth 3 is actually a guy
named Alexander Luthor now for those of
you guys who read Infinite Crisis the
Alexander Luthor that you recall is
actually the child version that we'll
see in this story that grows up rapidly
fast but the idea here is that we
initially pick up with a guy named
pariah now we'll find out more about
pariah later on and he's actually it's
actually kind of interesting the way his
story goes he's really like a scientist
and an explorer but basically he's being
forced to jump to different realities
and watch those realities die now all
Marvel really gives us here in the
beginning is just this idea that no one
can save this universe that Ultraman the
various members of the crime syndicate
they can't do anything to save their
reality that this universes version of
alexander luthor who's married to Lois
Lane they can't save their reality and
so in a very Superman esque sort of
situation once this this antimatter wave
begins sweeping through all known
existence they quite literally send
their child out now the reason why I say
this is Superman asked is that with
Krypton originally you know dying due to
its own destruction the result was that
the izzat jor-el sent his son sent
kal-el
into space and he arrived on earth and
much the same way they basically send
him into the multiverse now the reason
why this is done is because before
crisis on Infinite Earths
on earth one earth to and earth 3 had
crossed over before and so it wasn't as
though Alexander Luthor had no idea what
universes were out there he had an
inkling of an idea and he basically just
kind of sent the child into space more
or less hoping for the best and so what
we do is we transition to the
introduction of of two characters really
the introduction of one character and
the reintroduction of another the
character that were reintroduced to is a
girl named Lila now she's existed before
she first showed up in the Teen Titans I
believe um but she's basically
reintroduced here as a girl named
Harbinger she's effectively someone that
has the
of matter she Candace more let's
manipulate matter um but she is an
assistant of a guy named monitor now
again we'll get all this information
here later on in terms of where they
come from but Marv Wolfman and George
Perez are very finicky or not really
finicky they're very you know scant on
information in the beginning it's
instead it's more or less like realities
are ending and we're trying to save
people and that's basically it but what
he does is he goes to Harbinger and he
tasks her with finding heroes from
across all space and time from whatever
planets are left and so it's just kind
of like grab who you can't from where
you can and then bring him here and
that's exactly what she does she creates
duplicates of herself and she sends him
across multitudes of times so of course
she goes to like gorilla City for
example on earth and she ends up
grabbing their king she goes to the 30th
or 31st centuries and she grabs the
Legion of super-heroes now supposedly
guys who don't know the Legion of
super-heroes was a huge deal when it
first came out and because the DC one of
the big issues they ran into in the the
early ages of the publications is he had
the Justice League you had the Teen
Titans we have the Suicide Squad of what
will become the Suicide Squad so it was
like you know all the modern day teams
are basically covered and so the
question was what will really go from
there if you've covered the modern day
teams you can only have so many heroes
on so many teams because they don't have
an infinite number of heroes and so the
question was alright well let's let's
try something different and so they went
to the future basically and they said
here is a superhero team in the 30th and
31st centuries called the Legion of
super-heroes and it was wildly popular
and so what they did is they started
crossing them over with the Teen Titans
and some of our other heroes and it just
bolster their popularity even further
and so what we end up doing is we end up
grabbing a girl named dawn star and then
we just joined the rest of harbingers
clones and she starts grabbing other
people now behind the scenes and what
we'll actually learn later on is of
course because this story is you know
thirty years old what we end up finding
is that the 80 monitor who of course
again will get a little more expedition
about him a little more explanation on
his origin he has what are called shadow
demons and shadow demons are more or
less henchmen that work for him and
we'll see them you know as we progress
through this story but one of the shadow
demons latched itself on to one of the
duplicates of Harbinger and so when she
eventually reconsolidated herself it
resulted in her basically having a
fraction of the anti-monitor inside of
herself and what it does is it creates
this dichotomy where the side of her
this influenced by the anti-monitor says
kill them
auditor and the side is influenced by
the monitor doesn't want the monitor to
die and so it's it'll play out in an
easy-to-understand way as we get through
this but again this is really just her
grabbing people as they can now one of
the most important people that she grabs
is a guy named psycho pirate now
psycho-pirate has the ability to
manipulate the emotions of others and
initially it didn't seem like it was
going to be that big of a thing it
didn't seem like he was going to be that
significant but will find that when
psycho-pirate is joined by Barry Allen
when he's taken by the 80 monitor uh the
acquisition of cyclope rattan tea
monitor turns out to be one of the most
important things that he grabs here but
again Harbinger tracing these you know
just just take psycho-pirate and
initially seems to whisk him away to the
lair of the monitor so what we do here
is we basically join a lot of these
pre-crisis heroes for example Superman
from Earth 2 which is basically the
Golden Age of superheroes so Alan Scott
the Green Lantern you know Jay Garrick
the flash they're not here but that's
the era of heroes that they come from
this is basically the original Superman
from actually Comics number one we also
have Ted Kord Blue Beetle we have a
handful of others the Green Lantern Jon
Stewart it's basically just heroes
grabbed from different points in time
and they're all initially brought here
now they don't really know why and in
fact a lot of them seem to seem to argue
amongst themselves some of which is due
to the fact the soccer pirates starts
manipulating them but also because of
the fact that some of these these shadow
demons starts showing up out of nowhere
and start attacking these various heroes
now eventually they ask the question
what's going on here you know whoever
you are reveal yourself and the monitor
basically shows up it says hey this was
somewhat of a test I wanted to see
whether or not you can handle the task
that I'm going to to bestow on you
because all of your universes are
getting ready to die and so what we do
here is we initially pick up with a with
a young boy we pick up with a guy whose
name is anthro and anthro hails from a
future whereby humanity has been pushed
to the brink of extinction now he's not
the most important character ever in the
history of of stories but the only
reason why I mention here is because
we'll eventually pick up with Superman I
here in a little while and we'll join
him and I necessarily want you to be
without any explanation of who that guy
is but what happens here is there's
basically this sort of shuffling this
this you know mixing up of time and
space in the sense that we have an
thrower who witnesses the 30th century
before it immediately disappears we have
you know people in the in the
century who were suddenly met with the
arrival of woolly mammoths who were just
time-displaced
that's really all this happening is a
time in space is being disabled and is
being thrown awry and so picking back up
again with these various superheroes
meeting with the monitor of course again
the question is why we here what's going
on he says I've assembled you for the
purposes of trying to help me defeat my
phone now the monitor doesn't tell them
everything that's going on and in fact
he's very enigmatic to the to a lot of
these heroes there were stories that
took place before this where the monitor
began providing arms and even the
monitor monitor himself was providing
arms weapons and so on to various people
but that was designed to be a test to
see whether or not those heroes could
fight for the monitor and fight for the
anime monitor it was basically them this
kind of determining who would be best
suited to fight on their own fought on
each of their behalf but the result is
that the monitor has basically created
these giant pillars these energy towers
now those are the guys who read I want
to say was Geoff Johns Green Lantern had
dealt with the anti-monitor coming into
the control of the Black Lantern Corps
if you recall maybe wasn't for that
crisis on an herb herb there was a giant
tower that had the anti-monitor melded
into it this is where that comes from
this is where Geoff Johns grabbed that
kind of a thing and so again we
initially transition over to the
guardians of the universe now this is
only a quick thing and we actually won't
see them again for a little while but
the guardians of the universe are
actually the core reason for why this
happens for why we're having crisis on
Infinite Earths not them directly but
one of their guys named Crona and so
even though you know Marv Wolfman only
gives us a small glimpse even though he
has them analyzing this antimatter wave
and realized that seems there's nothing
they can do but they have to try their
best and while they aren't imprisoned or
they're kept in stasis I'd like you to
keep them in the back of your head
because they're gonna be wildly
important and so from here we jump to
earth one now earth one is basically the
universe that exists after the
introduction of Barry Allen and so all
the superheroes that you see that very
allen fights alongside Superman Wonder
Woman so on and so forth those are earth
one characters the superheroes that you
know the Green Lantern Alan Scott I
guess fights alongside that is earth too
so hopefully I can help you guys
differentiate things but but again we
basically join these heroes as they've
been dispersed throughout all space and
time to guard these towers that have
been created by the monitor now we don't
exactly know why
a lot of this was done but we suddenly
realized that the monitor is met with
the arrival of Alexander Luthor from
Earth 3 the last survivor of his
universe now initially it's just kind of
monitoring him it's really just keeping
an eye on him watching what happens but
the monitor is also curious about
Alexander Luthor because he's aging so
fast
but also because he has such a high
intelligence now transitioning back to
some of these superheroes who are who
are monitoring these towers you know
keeping an eye on these towers and
defending them of course again pariah
makes his presence known now with pariah
showing up here is basically just
another instance where he's being forced
to watch a watch of universe's
destruction and that's exactly what
happens ah this is you know where
initially we believed that it would be
kind of like a last battle at the Alamo
where earth one is where this final
battle would take place between the
monitor and the ants monitor or the
anti-monitor and the superheroes or
something like that instead that doesn't
happen
effectively all this stuff gets wiped
out earth 1 gets annihilated or 2 gets
annihilated but it's really gonna be
this mass panic that we'll start to
realize here in a second but again we
also transition back to anti-monitor as
he's taken psycho-pirate captive now the
interesting thing about this is we don't
see the anti-monitor until about halfway
through this story instead the
anti-monitor is just kind of this this
this disembodied voice that communicates
with psycho-pirate and the question
psycho-pirate has is why am I here and
anti-monitor says because you're the
most important piece of the board now
losing psycho-pirate for the monitor is
a huge deal and we'll find out why
because again it really seems to change
everything but picking up with earth 1
which is the comic book university you
guys are most familiar with is basically
the elimination of all things and it's
really people trying to understand
what's going on you have Wonder Woman
Donna Troy you have Dick Grayson
Nightwing you have Superman you know you
have all these heroes that are that are
trying to figure things out Batman
doesn't even really know what's going on
but in truth this antimatter wave is
sweeping throughout this cosmos so fast
that none of them really have time to
react and so while flash you know
reappears to them after having vanished
previously and says hey look we have to
find a way to stop this like this world
is going to end but there's still a way
to save things he suddenly just
disappears he simply just vanishes and
no one initially knows where he goes to
and so again marvel
and really gives us an idea of just how
grave this situation is just how many
people are watching what's going on when
we switched to Brainiac now Brainiac is
really just kind of out in space here
he's really just doing whatever it is
Brainiac does when he's not fighting
Superman or attacking earth and he comes
to this realization that there is an
antimatter wave sweeping throughout the
cosmos now Brady act with his extremely
advanced intellect also realizes that
this antimatter wave simply cannot be
stopped it doesn't seem as though
there's a way to bring it to an end but
if there's anybody on earth that may
have a way to end it it's Lex Luthor
from earth 1 it's it's election that we
are the most familiar with and so what
we do here is again we pick up with a
couple of a few of the heroes here and
there who are fighting against these
various forces some of whom are
time-displaced they're thrown out of
their own time period they're thrown
into a future time period or something
like that you know we pick up with like
Ted Kord Blue Beetle who's trying to
guard one of these one of these powers
but they're also fending off against the
shadow demons of anti-monitor it's
really just not Marv Wolfman kind of
giving us a quick run-through of what's
going on with a lot of these heroes and
the reason why he does this is because
while that's happening we have the
heroes on earth one trying to understand
everything and trying to bring
everything to an end and suddenly we
have Harbinger who's basically taken
over by the influence of the
anti-monitor
who turns her weapons against monitor
and who annihilates him who completely
White's him out and so the question that
people have now is what's going to
happen with pariah having been thrown
from University universe and watching
each universe die
and having been thrown into the presence
of the monitor pariah is nil is now in a
situation where he believes that there's
no way to save the multiverse there's
nothing that can be done now something
else that I also want to do here is I
want to turn your attention to the new
doctor light now those are the guys who
were following DC in the 1990s you
recognize this version of dr. light I'm
sure that you do and the reason for this
is because the monitor had this idea
that there's basically going to need to
be someone who can rally the heroes
together or the very least who can stand
at the precipice really among the ranks
now the reason why I say this is because
dr. light is exactly what it sounds like
it's you know and in this instance dr.
lights able to manipulate all forms of
life but the reason why this matters is
because the shadow demons of the anti
have a weakness to light and so what
this would mean is that if all else
fails if these pillars were to converge
into a single location then dr. light
would quite literally be able to fend
them off by herself just by absorbing
light from anything that emits light
around her absorbing that light into
herself I'm in just continually shining
it in keeping the shadow demons away
it's really just a way for the monitor
to buy time to keep the shadow demons
song that's one reason why I say dr.
light would really be kind of like at
the precipice of these heroes because
while they have to fight the shadow
demons at hand-to-hand combat doctor
lied could defeat them in the most
feasible way possible and so again we
pick up here with with a lot of these
superheroes you know going against a lot
of these super shadow demons again it's
really just kind of a way to just show
us exactly what's happening in this in
this point and time but ultimately we're
basically met with pariah meeting
alongside the monitor prior to his death
and then having to witness the monitor
die and so what we have is this
situation where earth to an earth one
basically seemed to be gone that the
multiverse in its entirety seems to have
been completely eliminated I so the
question that we have is if this is the
case if the entry matter wave of the
anti-monitor was successful in
eliminating the entirety of the
multiverse there wonder what have
happened to these heroes what's going on
and what we learned was that you know
the monitor dying was part of this plan
and the reason for this was because the
vast powers that he possessed you know
to manipulate reality and its entirety
were limited by his physical body and so
after his death he basically reveals a
hologram image or a recording - to Lyla
- Harbinger and two pariah and he says
this is this was my plan that by
destroyed my physical body you've
released my energies into what remains
or what used to be existence and what
I've done is I basically created
something called the nether verse and
the nether verse is essentially like
this little sliver a little pocket
dimension is very akin to battle world
from secret Wars for those of you guys
who read that story and it's essentially
a place where he's gathered what remains
of what he could grab and store them
there and so there are heroes there are
planets there are locations that exist
from the remainder of the multiverse
prior to its collapse that have all been
stationed here the problem with this is
that as people from all spaces and all
times and so you have dinosaur
in the 30th century you have soldiers
from world war ii who were in the modern
day they're seeing things they'd never
experienced before now initially this
wasn't a huge deal but the most notable
heroes from throughout all space and
time all history of the DC Multiverse
had been gathered together under the
direction of Harbinger and the now older
alexander luthor who's basically grown
in to really pass adolescence into his
20s or so as well as pariah and when
they bring them here they basically say
yes the actions of the monitor
you know resulted in his death yes that
was part of his plan but it's all left
to us and he says the only way they can
basically a win is of course to defeat
the anti-monitor or at least defeat
whatever this foe is but also to
essentially create one universe and this
is basically where Marv Wolfman is
coming along and saying this is the
purpose of crisis on Infinite Earths the
purpose of crisis on Infinite Earths is
not to recreate the multiverse the
purpose of the story is to effectively
eliminate the multiverse and then create
one universe going forward and so again
the other half of this is that because
of the fact that psycho-pirate
has been brought before the anti-monitor
and the moments before the multiverse
was collapsed near the most for its
entire collapse and in the time it took
between when it was collapsing and when
the monitor grabbed whatever he could
and brought them over to this nether
verse that antimatter had reached out
and grabbed a character named Red
Tornado now those of you guys who were
reading the new 52 or those of us who
read the earth 2 line of stories and new
52 that name will sound familiar to you
Red Tornado will be familiar and the
reason why is because in earth 2 in the
new 52 Red Tornado was basically an
Android with female features that had
the mind of Lois Lane inside of it and
the crisis on Infinite Earths story arc
red tornado is his own being as his own
entity but what anti-monitor says is
that a set of Red Tornado manipulating
winds and so on and so forth the red
Toyota was a vastly powerful being now
red tornado was effectively going to
serve as part of the anti monitors
machine and creating this antimatter
wave that's going to eliminate the
nether verse and its entirety with the
intention of recreating the multiverse
as an antimatter multiverse that's
really what the anti-monitor is shooting
for we'll find out why here in a little
bit but with psycho-pirate having been
told that operating as a henchman of the
anti-monitor would mean
that he would be able to basically
manipulate a world of his own or I guess
you know a reality of his own he's
basically told yes this is exactly what
you're going to get you're going to get
the ability to manipulate realities of
your own this will we get the actual
plan of the anti-monitor what he does
here is he basically bolsters the power
of of psycho-pirate cycle parse ability
to manipulate emotions are now planetary
level really you know Universal level
and what he does is he basically has the
anti-monitor tap into the emotions of
all these people who exist on the
fragments of realities in this nether
verse and essentially manipulate their
emotions and start turning them against
one another
now while this happens we also have the
guardians of the universe that are still
alive in the nether verse and we also
have Ultron which is still alive in the
nether verse and it grabbed Lex Luthor
from earth 1 and so it was really more
of this thing where when the multiverse
collapsed the monitor had just reached
out grabbed people wherever they
happened to be at that time and brought
them into the nether verse and so things
are pretty much the same as far as they
remember for those who are out in space
and weren't actually on planets but
again because of the fact that all these
different heroes are fighting one
another we basically have like Shazam
fighting against Supergirl it's really
one of these scenarios where it's kind
of the dream matches that a lot of
people always wanted to see but it's
also a less expansive version of the
battle world events that we saw in
seeker wars for Marvel Comics and so
what we have here is is essentially
Delilah coming to this realization that
the influence of psycho-pirate is
dependent on his power boost from the
anti-monitor
and so in order to keep everybody from
fighting themselves she basically burns
her powers out what she does is she
essentially moves the entirety of the
nether verse away from the influence of
the anti-monitor and while it does
restore things to normal she's
inherently human now she has no super
powers
she basically burned them all out in an
attempt to essentially keep everybody
alive and so with the destruction of the
monitor's fortress the question that
everybody has now is what's next
not only that they also have a lot of
questions that haven't been answered on
who the monitor was who their actual foe
is how all this stuff works and what
exactly is taking place and so what Marv
Wolfman does is he effectively gives us
this sort of end-all-be-all origin of
all things and what he tells us is that
when this universe came into existence
originally there was only
one universe there was only one DC
universe which we could call earth 1 but
what had happened was somewhere along
the line after the guardians of the
universe once the once the Owens
basically kind of elevated themselves in
science and so on and so forth one of
their kind a guy named Corona wanted to
witness the origin of all things but it
was forbidden but despite this fact he
used a computer to witness the origin of
creation and in doing so not only gave
birth to the multiverse but also gave
birth to the antimatter universe now
what this did is this basically created
two opposing sides the evil antimatter
universe and the good for at least for
lack of a better word good positive
matter of multiverse in response to this
the the Owens form themselves are
christened themselves as the guardians
of the universe they imprisoned Crona
and they set about basically correcting
the error of their mistakes looking for
a way to create superheroes are looking
for a way to create a place for the
universe that could basically offset
this introduction of evil and so what
they did is they initially created the
Manhunters and when the Manhunters
proved to be a failure
they created the Green Lantern Corps now
behind the scenes we also had a group of
Owens who didn't necessarily see things
the exact same way the Guardians did
instead well the Guardians wanted to use
the Green Lantern's as a peacekeeping
force some of the Owens wanted to use
them as soldiers getting rid of what
they called undesirables the problem
with this went to the term undesirables
was an open term there was really no
definition on what undesirables meant
and so the guardians saw this as the
first steps to creating addictive you
know dictatorial universe and so instead
they basically engaged in a civil war
with these other Owens that you know had
really harsh views and as a result the
guardians of the universe maintained
control over the positive matter
multiverse and they in turn they sent
the evil Owens off to the antimatter
universe where they took up residence on
a on a planet called cord now while they
were on this planet cord they
effectively evolved into what we call
the weapon years that's where these came
from but while all this had been
happening when the multiverse had been
formed the monitor came into existence
and when the antimatter universe had
been formed the anti-monitor came into
existence the kicker was that they had
just slept
they were basically dormant but
eventually the anti-monitor woke up now
we weren't initially told how the
we learned was that this is why pariah
is more or less being forced to witness
all these things as kind of the penance
that he's paying
Briah scientists much like Crona the
issue was that when he set about
exploring the origin of creation he
inadvertently woke up the anti-monitor
and when he did the anti-monitor
destroyed his world and that began a
conquest to basically start wiping out
everything and absorbing all the
antimatter energy in existence to make
itself this absolute ruler with the
purpose of wiping out all things in
existence and then recreating the
universe or the multiverse as an
antimatter multiverse and so in response
to this the monitor started realizing
what was going on and they fought one
another which ultimately leads us up to
where we are right now so what this does
is it basically creates the status quo
it tells us were things are at this
moment and it gives us the origin of the
DC Universe before crisis on Infinite
Earths now something to keep in mind is
it for those of you guys who jumped into
DC Comics with like the Justice League
dark side war the information that you
found in there gets rid of all this
stuff it basically replaces all this
stuff is what's called a retcon or
retroactive continuity who a writer
comes back and they change the status
quo with regards to what it is that
they're doing and that's essentially
what what do you did of course there's a
lot of things that go into that but
that's more or less the just of this in
addition to all this kind of stuff this
this exposition
we're also met by the arrival of the
Phantom Stranger and the spectre now the
Phantom Stranger is like this II
magmatic being that's just wildly
powerful and no one's ever really
explored that as far as I know we don't
really know the full heights of his
abilities we don't really know anything
about him that's why he's called the
Phantom Stranger is he has the
capability to do or at least it seems
though he can do almost anything he just
never really does when it comes to Jim
Corrigan when it comes to the spectre
he's like the wrath of God but one of
the kicker's to this and it may have
been something that I that I miss I'm
not really sure but one of the kicker's
here seems to be that for whatever
reason the powers of Jim Corrigan don't
really work to their fullest in the
antimatter universe as it stands to
right now now it seems as though the
reason behind this is because the
anti-monitor has just absorbed so much
antimatter energy that it basically just
negates the powers of of Jim Corrigan
that seems to be the case but we're not
entirely sure at least I'm not entirely
sure again if you guys know something
that I don't feel free to post it down
in the comment section below but moving
on to Alexander Luthor the reason why
his character was so important here is
that when he passed through the
dimensional barrier but
the time it took for him to get from
Earth three prior to his to his
destruction and arriving in the realm of
the monitor he had basically become like
a living energy conduit now he has the
ability to harness both positive and
antimatter and in turn he can basically
create portals to anywhere and he can
create dimensions and that's that's what
he does and in fact this will be a major
component when it comes to the end of
this story with regards to
superboy-prime to earth to Superman to
earth to Lois Lane and even Alexander
Luthor himself which will actually be
picked back up once you guys get into
Infinite Crisis which is where all that
kind of stuff comes from but we'll talk
about that once we get you know what
we'll cross that bridge when we get
there but because of the fact that the
anti-monitor still resides in the
antimatter universe and they're more or
less just kind of left in this no-man's
land of the nether verse alexander
luthor says okay fine i will create a
portal i'll create a way for us to
access the antimatter universe and we
will go there and we will fight the
anti-monitor directly and that's exactly
what they do now interestingly enough
about this is that the villains actually
have their own plans and it actually
kind of works and we'll get to that here
in a second but we end up joining these
super heroes does they immediately get
in to the antimatter universe but what
Marv Wolfman does is he also provides
some caveats here specifically when it
comes to the various members of the
Superman family Supergirl Superman from
Earth once ran through earth to the
issue with them is that they've
basically lost their invulnerability
their super-strength remains their
flight their you know heat vision all
that stuff still there but it's
basically just Marv Wolfman taking away
from making these characters a deus ex
machina you know where they can just
basically in the entire situation
because in truth any foe that Superman
from Earth to that super girl curves or
L goes against that Superman from Earth
one if they were to fight them all you
know fight that being with all three of
them fighting at the same time they
would probably lay waste to the
anti-monitor and so by giving them a
weakness making them you know easy to to
kill basically by losing invulnerability
that makes it possible for the story to
have a compelling ending and so while
they do face off against some of these
threats of the anti-monitor
what I want to do here is I want to
transition away from these various
superheroes and I want to move over to
the death of Kara zor-el now the death
of Kara zor-el was huge when this
happened I mean this was this was nuts
because when when she first appeared she
had a huge following a lot of people
really really liked her the kicker was a
lot of people also saw her as like a
spinoff of super
I started to go away and she began to
grow in a sense that while she was
technically a spinoff she also developed
her own character it was also done
really really well but one of the
questions people had is how powerful is
Supergirl in relation to Superman and
people always said well Superman's more
powerful what Marv Wolfman did in this
story is he said while anti-monitor was
facing off against all these heroes
while anti-monitor was taking all of
them out one by one Kara zor-el was the
last man standing she was the one the
last person who was able to fend off
against the anti-monitor
and held out the longest and so what
what Marvel from basically said here is
that between Superman earth one between
Superman from Earth two and Kara zor-el
from Earth one she's the most powerful
out of all of them the most capable and
is solidified what a lot of people liked
about her character but it solidified
what a lot of people wanted to and so
what happens here is that with her death
Superman from from Earth one loses it
because this was his cousin this was a
part of his family and he's so outraged
and so distraught at the experience you
know that he feels like he should be the
one that should lay her to rest he
should be the one that should take her
out and give her a proper burial and you
know what remains of the fortress of
solitude because again all these
different earths are still confined
within this another verse and so from
here I want to jump over to Barry Allen
to the death of Barry Allen because this
is one of the other huge things to
happen in the story Barry Allen's
character had basically been popping in
and out of time throughout this story
and I'd actually skipped over that and
the reason why was because it would have
seemed weird and out of place and I was
afraid it might a phony guys off but
since his capture by the inky monitor
Barry Allen has basically been
manipulated time and time again by
psycho-pirate and effectively just
torture to the point where Barry Allen
has to remember these terrible
experiences yes you remember the happy
experiences that he can never go back to
and it's really just a way to mess with
his mind at the same time we also have
dark side from the new gods and
apocalypse which exist in this another
verse now Darkseid in this situation is
actually really intriguing because he
doesn't actually do anything and that's
one of the funny situations here is
because we would expect someone as
capable as Darkseid to either ally
himself with the anti-monitor
or ally himself with a super heroes but
it's some former fashion he would fight
instead he says nope we're gonna stay
hands off and we're gonna wait and the
reason why is he says if the superheroes
are successful things will go back to
the way they used to be and I'll be
doing the exact same thing I did before
if the
heroes are not successful they would
have put up one hell of a fight which
means that anti-monitor would be weaker
which means I can defeat him and I can
recreate reality the way that I wanted
to be and so for him it's really just a
waiting game it's just an intelligent
game to play to see how things end up
and so again you know with Barry Allen
picking up with his character he had
basically been kind of stirring in his
powers because they had gradually been
coming back while they had been
suppressed during his time under the
control of the of the anti-monitor and
when he makes his escape he's able to
easily subdue a psycho-pirate here and
he immediately takes off to the core of
this antimatter cannon but the
anti-monitor has a symbol because the
goal of the anti-monitor is to use his
can and fire it into oblivion and
recreate all things and so Barry Allen
comes to the realization of course as a
scientist that if this cannon is
composed of antimatter that is core to
take a sufficient amount of positive
manner to basically destroy it but so
his idea is to basically reverse the
polarity of this cannon by running in
the the direction counter to where this
cyclones going and so he basically
creates a wind tunnel effect that
reverses the spin of this antimatter
cannon effectively dispersing the
antimatter in its entirety and destroys
the cannon but in the process of doing
this he starts fluctuating throughout
all space and time and this is why those
of you guys who go and read crisis on
Infinite Earths you'll see moments where
he just pops up and he sees Batman for a
second and says hey you have to save us
and then vanishes this is likely what's
happening with regards to the Batman
Superman movie when we saw the flash
appear out of nowhere this is the kind
of thing that was taking place as he was
basically fluctuating throughout all
space and time but ultimately his
actions are successful and destroy the
antimatter cannon and the problem is
that he simply ceases to exist now when
this story happened the initial belief
was that Barry Allen died that was at
that process Barry Allen's gone he's
dead and he's never coming back as we
found out with Final Crisis he was
basically just lost in the Speed Force
that was really all that was going on
and so because of this it's really just
kind of like this Last Man Standing it's
this this final battle or at least it
seems to be this final battle is taking
place between the superheroes that
remain and you know those those people
who are basically trying to take their
place or at least villains who are just
doing villains stuff now the kicker with
this is that when it comes to the
regular super villains that we're used
to they have their own plan in the sense
that the only way to keep this cycle
from repeating is to go back in time and
to stop Crona
from observing the universe in the first
place the problem with this is that
they're super villains
so would they do that when they travel
back into the past and they try to stop
Crona they also really start fighting
among one another which results in Crona
observing the origin of all things
anyway in addition to this with these
various forces who are fighting amongst
themselves Jim Corrigan pops up and says
hey you guys have to stop this you know
the anti-monitor is not dead the
anti-monitor is alive and we have to
work to essentially destroy him and from
here this is where things get a little
weird from here we're suddenly met by
the arrival of superboy-prime now this
is really just Marv Wolfman throwing
superboy-prime into the story there was
a story arc in I think it was ICI
presents issue number 81
um and that explained where it was that
he came from what you guys can actually
find that in my video on superboy-prime
explained but the fact is is that he's
here now superboy-prime is wildly
powerful in terms of the remnants of
these various supermen who were left
superboy-prime is the most powerful out
of all of them but the idea here is to
basically find the anti-monitor and to
eliminate him before he can you know
essentially try to wipe all things out
or at least wipe out with what remains
of these superheroes and so because of
the fact that Crona is able to witness
the anti-monitor I guess witness the
creation of all things because of the
fact that the anti-monitor is able to
travel back to the creation of all
things we learned that the hand that
Crona witnessed was the anti monitors
hand rising up but the view screens that
the villains are watching in the past as
they're standing alongside Crona it
actually changes so that when Spectre
and the anti-monitor are fighting one
another that they see the hand of the
Spectre and the anti-monitor so it's
basically just an idea of how this
multiversal battle is influencing the
origin of all creation and so what isn't
happening is that in this this conflict
between the anti-monitor inspector it
results in the fracturing of reality as
it seems to exist and everything comes
crashing down and then it immediately
reforms in the form of new earth now the
kicker about this is that all these
heroes have no histories as far as the
universe is concerned this is day one
and they're all just here and so there's
no backstories they have no origin
stories um it's almost as if the
character had just been written and no
nobody ever wrote a backstory for them
that's basically where we are right now
and so the stage is set Marv Wolfman has
made the slate he's set a stage for the
origin stories that these characters
will get after crisis on Infinite Earths
is over but what we also learned here is
that the anti-monitor is not necessarily
dead the ante
essence still exists and so what we have
is the situation where Superman from
Earth to realizes that his wife Lois
Lane is dead Superman from Earth one
real you know knows the Supergirl is
dead the lives they had before are gone
and so they basically have to make do as
best they can not only that once the
anti-monitor reconstructs itself or at
least sari constructs its essence and
begins reforming its physical body the
Superman from Earth to lashes out north
to has had and had enough of everything
the anti-monitor is doing and so what he
does and this is actually one of the
most impressive displays of power in
this story Superman earth who just loses
it and ultimately just punches the
absolute [ __ ] out of the entity monitor
to the point that it seems to disperse
his energies in its entirety now of
course we also have a lot of other
superheroes who are fighting alongside
him as well but the goal here is that
the ante monitors essence has
effectively been completely obliterated
the anti-monitor has been completely
destroyed and so what this does is this
allows the superheroes to begin trying
to figure out what they're going to do
next to try to get things sorted out now
with regards to those of you guys who
read Infinite Crisis this is where
things began to pick up this is where
you guys got earth to Superman a
superboy-prime who ended up going on a
rampage this is where they came from
what happened was that with earth Q
completely gone you know Alexander
Luthor reveals that Lois Lane is alive
that she hasn't had effectively been
reborn with new earth but he had kept
her hidden away from the danger so that
she wouldn't be killed in the conflict
because she would have been brought back
you know exactly where all this this all
this was happening and so when her
presence is revealed Alexander Luthor
basically says we're people without a
home we have nowhere to go
and so essentially he takes them all or
whisk them all away to a pocket
dimension now originally this was
supposed to be the end this was gonna be
the end of the earth to Superman this
was gonna be the end of superboy-prime
this is gonna be the end of Earth to
Lois Lane there's stories we're gonna be
finished and they were for 20 years
until Geoff Johns brought him back and
Infinite Crisis but as a story wraps up
all it basically says is that we're
getting a start of allure basically
getting a refresh that these characters
are gonna start getting their own origin
stories that what Barry Allen having
been killed that Wally West now takes
his place due to the fact that he was
his age was jump-started when the new
earth was reformed is essentially you
know this idea that we have a
continuation of a lot of the characters
that we like but the origin stories of
where they came from are gonna be told
in publications coming after so
finishing Green Lantern vol 1 no fear um
I was going through a lot of the Green
Lantern stuff I mean I'm like I'm into
two blackest night right now in terms of
reading blackest night is amazing oh my
god that story so good
Sinestro Corps war was stellar I think
Sinestro Corps war is better but it
there there are amazing stories when you
get to that level of storytelling it's
pretty much as easy to say they're both
amazing I mean you're really getting
into like nuanced differences but
getting going into a Green Lantern Corps
recharge of course what that does is it
basically focuses on the Green Lantern
Corps so like Kilowog the new Green
Lantern's who are being trained Guy
Gardner Kyle Rayner Jon Stewart but it
also kind of ties into the idea of
superboy-prime still being held by the
Green Lantern's and what I initially
thought about doing was just kind of
saying hey here's what happened to
support Tron yada yada yada
but I also kind of realized that in DC
there are like intrinsically great
stories or stories of this kind of need
to be told and an Infinite Crisis is a
story that I've wanted to tell and so
what we're gonna do in this video is
we're gonna run over countdown to
Infinite Crisis now what countdown to
Infinite Crisis did is it was basically
like an 85 page one-shot and it set the
seeds for a lot of stories that were
coming after project Omak the ran Fenig
are war villains United and I don't
remember the last one I feel like the
last one is the most important one but
the fact remains here that it basically
was kind of set the stage for for a
handful of stories here and there and it
went forward with the idea of basically
telling us here are the the events that
led to the start of Infinite Crisis
here's how it all kind of kind of came
together in a way that basically made
something a little more cohesive day a
vengeance that's the last one there we
go but I couldn't I couldn't remove that
last title for the life of me but this
story almost focuses exclusively on on
Blue Beetle
but it's done in a way that makes sense
now for those of you guys who were
reading a Justice League versus Suicide
Squad and you had a particular interest
in like Maxwell Lord and you were trying
to figure out about his character where
he basically kind of became a major
villain what the story does is answer
those questions I mean well it really
kind of lays the groundwork for
answering those questions but
superboy-prime and company don't really
show up until like Infinite Crisis but
again it's kind of sets the stage for
things that go on
we might be kind of picky and choosey
based on you know what miniseries we do
we'll probably just stick with only a
couple of them and then we'll just jump
directly into infinite crisis but what
this does is it initially just kind of
picks up with Blue Beetle making his way
into the headquarters of checkmate now
because this was a countdown to Infinite
Crisis it really just kind of followed
the trend of zero hour crisis and time
in a sense that zero hour crisis in time
was actually a miniseries or instead of
going to issues you know one two three
or four five six
it started with six and worked its way
down to a zero issue and that's what
this little story does it really just
kind of you know jumps back in time so
what we end up doing here is you
basically jump back to four days ago now
of course Ted Kord the current version
of Blue Beetle was hanging out with
Barbara Gordon who again is still
paralyzed following the events of The
Killing Joke again it is basically
alerted to the idea that somebody is
funneling money somebody's laundering
money through through Ted kord's company
the issue with this is that it basically
kind of is effectively bankrupting Ted
Kord and so of course this kind of
leaves him on a merry chase where he's
trying to figure out what's going on but
again it kind of sets the stage because
keep in mind Infinite Crisis was billed
as like the 20th anniversary of crisis
on Infinite Earths it was one of those
things worse like if you read any story
you got to read this one it's o
countdown was basically designed to
introduce new readers so we get the sort
of tour so we basically transitioned
over to to Booster Gold now a lot of
this comes out of identity crisis and
identity crisis basically dealt with a
pretty severe situation where the woman
named sue did me in order to keep it
family-friendly we're not gonna go t do
too deep into it but comic story and
does have a video on it suffice it to
say the the incident basically involved
sexual assault we'll leave it there but
in response the memories of a lot of
superheroes of almost the entire Justice
League were basically wiped and so what
this did is it basically created a rift
with regards to a lot of the different
members creating trust issues among them
but what Blue Beetle does is he kind of
gives us a little bit of a rollercoaster
in terms of how he viewed himself
alongside Booster Gold because when
Booster Gold and Blue Beetle came on
they were part of Justice League
International and again Justice League
International was the reworked Justice
League team following crisis on Infinite
Earths remember after after crisis was
over there was no like main justice Li
there was no Batman Superman Wonder
Woman the flash Green Lantern and so on
there there was no Justice League team
like that instead it was just the
unsellable I mean I hate to use that
term but it was basically the characters
that couldn't hold a book on their own
but it was a way for DC to basically
treat the Justice League like a
revolving door
introduce new superheroes that people
would normally never read give them some
exposure and then turn around and give
them their own solo series if they prove
to be popular the funny thing about this
was that Blue Beetle was basically I
guess really Blue Beetle and Booster
Gold but kind of like the one-two punch
of comedy on the team and so that's one
of the reasons why a lot of people
really loved the two of them together
because it has kind of went together
like like you know a peanut butter and
jelly I mean they were just they were
they were great in terms of how they
functioned with one another the problem
is that after the events of identity
crisis Booster Gold had basically walked
away from being a superhero he said I
can't really do this anymore well the
problem was that all the gimmicks all
the money all the the draw and the
facades that went with him being Booster
Gold basically went along with it and so
he was for all intents and purposes
completely broke now there were
instances where he tried to kind of get
back on his feet and that's really what
happens here you know we circle draws
the attention of Blue Beetle
when Booster Gold basically you know
draws 300 bucks out of an ATM machine
using you know money that the Blue
Beetle has of course Blue Beetle says
hey look we're kind of broke here and
I'm we're running on fumes in terms of
cash but Blue Beetle also says look
somebody's embezzling money somebody's
laundering money through my company and
if there's any one person that would be
most likely to do this it would be
Maxwell Lord now keep in mind Maxwell
Lord was basically kind of kind of
brought in with regards to Justice
League International as a guy that
effectively stole leadership away from
Batman I mean he really just kind of
hijacked the team but it was really cool
because Maxwell Lord was kind of uh one
of these characters of DC was trying to
sort out they were trying to figure out
what direction they were gonna take him
in and they struggled time and time
again because Maxwell Lord was not
inherently interesting but what this
does is kind of pick his character and
turn him on his head again now of course
getting with Maxwell Lord meeting with
Maxwell Lord the the meetings pretty
short-lived and the sense that Lord
basically says look guys your best years
are behind you I mean you guys got to
stop looking at being superheroes
you guys gotta basically is kind of look
at the future and see what direction you
want your lives to go on well there's
really no answers to be had here and so
when is up happening is it's Booster
Gold I'm sorry Blue Beetle basically
turns his attention to Bruce Wayne and
that's really what's gonna happen in the
story Blue Beetle is gonna go from
Justice League member to Justice League
member telling them what's going on and
none of them are really going to take
him seriously keep in mind that when it
came to Booster Gold and when it came to
to Blue Beetle
they were playing second fiddle I mean
when people thought of the Justice
League when they thought of the world's
greatest superheroes they didn't think
of Ted Kord
the other didn't think of Blue Beetle
they didn't think of Booster Gold I
don't mean in terms of fans I mean it's
rows with just society in the DC
and so because of that you know they
thought it would be a Batman someone and
so forth and so we know Ted Kord I guess
a Blue Beetle Booster Gold they were
background guys they were second second
rate guys and even the Justice League
looked at them that way to a degree
however speaking with Batman and
basically saying hey look you know
somebody's doing something I mean
there's information that's going on
rumors about dr. lights so on and so
forth again all of that tying in to
identity crisis Batman really kind of
blows them off but what we ended up
finding out is that because of the
events of identity crisis Batman had
basically created this sort of
autonomous system called brother I and
what brother I was designed to do was
basically monitor the planet Earth to be
really kind of be one of these you know
Batman's I in the sky so to speak to
kind of make the earth I guess a safer
place now again we're gonna find out
later on in this video how it can be
used for nefarious purposes but again
Jimmy back over to to Blue Beetle you
know in the present moment right now
investigating really the the
headquarters of checkmate he's coming
across all these different files
belonging to Batman Superman you know
the the Green Lantern Hal Jordan keep in
mind this comes after Green Lantern
rebirth you know investigating at the
flash isn't one and so forth and there's
all these files all these these dossiers
you don't want them and what these
profiles basically do is they list their
secret identities their strengths their
weaknesses all this information so for
those of you guys who read like Tower of
Babel where Batman was keeping detailed
files on how to defeat the individual
members of the Justice League
imagine that information but expanded to
include almost the entirety of the
superhero community or at least the most
prominent members as well as the various
organizations that exist out there
protein tech star labs so on and so
forth and so again because of this what
is up happening as we actually find out
Ted Kord wonder that one of the I guess
warehouses that was owned by Ted Kord
had basically been raided it has stored
several hundred pounds of Kryptonite and
again this was a major issue just simply
because of the fact that if a person got
a hold of this kryptonite they could use
it for any number of reasons on Superboy
Conner Kent because remember following
the death of Superman there was no
Conner Kent during the reign of the
Superman he was a holdover he was
maintained by DC Comics he's still
around and he actually has a really
badass well in Infinite Crisis when he
fights superboy-prime it's pretty
amazing I love that fight but what Blue
Beetle does is he kind of reaches out to
Oracle says you know we did call
everybody Emily to find out who Jack to
this kryptonite so we've got you know
we've got dr. fate we got power girl hot
girls so on and so forth but again what
this does is highlight the lack of trust
between these different members of the
Justice League team and so because of
that
of individuals kind of look at blue
beetle and say look we're just kind of
doing this as a favor but honestly man
there's really nothing to go on here
you're kind of wasting your time a lot
of them don't really take him seriously
and oh you know one by one slowly but
surely they all sort of begin to bail
out now of course how Jordan appears
before Blue Beetle and says hey look my
rings picking up some very trace or very
faint signatures of radiation but what
this tells us is that whoever it was
that took this kryptonite did so with
stealth in mind that if some of the
world's greatest superheroes Power Girl
with all her different abilities to star
fire with all her different abilities
dr. fate in the realm of magic if all
these different individuals cannot find
any real trace of evidence to indicate
who it was that took the script tonight
or where well then suddenly Blue Beetle
begins to lose credibility he's the boy
who cried wolf
but with Hal Jordan on Blue Beetle side
of the saying look I'm willing to help
you you know deal with this it kind of
bolsters a confidence of Lou Beale it
makes him feel like he's less of a
second-stringer
and makes him feel like he has more of a
place or at least somebody out there is
taking him seriously now of course when
the questions asked what happened to the
script tonight and where did it go
Superman makes his up here so that's one
of the coolest things about this because
Blue Beetle looks at this looks at
Superman it says every time I see him
it's the first time every time I see him
no matter when I see him no matter where
I see him no matter how many times I've
seen him before every time is the first
time his authority the stance that he
has the fact that he's so large the
confidence that he exudes you know it
really makes Ted Kord kind of feel
insignificant but the fact that Superman
is speaking to him and taking time to
talk to him makes him feel important so
really is one of these funny little
moments one of these funny little things
in terms of how different people view
the concept of the character of Superman
not only that Ted Kord actually starts
tripping over his words he starts
getting nervous his mouth dries up he
doesn't really know what to say Superman
says calm down relax tell me what's
happening now of course Blue Beetle
explains everything that's going on with
regard to the Kryptonite that vanished
Superman takes this with the utmost
concern and says look if there's a
hundred pounds of kryptonite running
around out there it's you know for
Superman and the various kryptonite
based individuals out there it might as
well be an atomic bomb and so it's like
that line from the movie peacemaker I'm
not concerned about the guy who wants 10
Nuge I'm concerned about the guy who
only wants one and so because of this if
Superman kind of say okay look this
deserves a lot of attention now of
course he races off but then blue
beetles sort of accosted by these
nonsensical villains and so on and so
forth now the funny
about this and this is why I love the
story so much is because on the surface
it seems woefully unimportant it seems
totally unimportant in fact it's almost
over in the blink of an eye in the sense
that these guys are basically chased off
by Booster Gold who returns to help Blue
Beetle but will actually find out later
on this was extremely important this was
a very significant moment in this story
more so than that again this basically
kind of sets the seeds for villains
United when we find out that Lex Luthor
is working alongside a black Adam he's
working alongside Talia al Ghul he's
working alongside dr. psycho Deathstroke
basically creating this this new team of
supervillains for the purpose of
carrying out whatever missions or goals
they intend to carry out again a lot of
this kind of sets the stage for some of
the stories we're gonna be coming out of
this some of the miniseries that lead
into Infinite Crisis but from this point
we jump forward you know a little bit
you know by about a day and a half or so
two and a half days something like that
and we basically pick up with you know
Blue Beetle and Booster Gold sort of
going through and trying to figure out
what's going on the reason for this is
because of the fact that in blue beetles
mind if someone was contracted to
basically Rob his Robbins place you know
robbed this warehouse then money had to
have changed hands and if money changed
hands then it could be traceable because
in the worst of Blue Beetle people don't
just change exchange money using
suitcases anymore it's all done
digitally now keep in mind Blue Beetle
is wildly intelligent in terms of what
it is he's capable of but he also has a
great deal of wealth to his name and has
a lot of resources at his disposal the
problem is that in the middle of this
whole investigation when Booster Gold
steps up to try to you know get into
this computer and trace these
transactions the whole thing explodes
the whole house is basically totally
destroyed now what this does is it sends
Blue Beetle on a chase to find out who
it was that destroyed this house and the
reason why is because of the fact that
this damage also includes Booster Gold
receiving third-degree burns on 40% of
his chest so at this point it's really
become personal
more so than business-related now of
course at this point the the
investigations of Blue Beetle basically
lead him to the rock of eternity now the
rock of eternity at least as far as I'm
aware the rock of eternity is where the
wizard Shazam resides keep him on Shazam
is basically the wizard that bestowed
Billy Batson with his powers and allowed
him to become you know Captain Marvel Oh
Shazam or whatever you want to call him
but you know this guy that the powers
that this guy bestowed is the reason why
Billy Batson can shout the word Shazam
and turn into a superhero the issue with
this is that when it comes to the wizard
Shazam he has a great deal of knowledge
on a lot of
things that are going on keep in mind
this is all still in the era where
there's only one singular universe but a
lot of this is kept cloak-and-dagger we
don't really know what's going on the
wizard Shazam speaks in a very cryptic
way saying things like there's a lot
unfolding at the moment there's a lot
going on behind the scenes you know
there are a lot of things that are
taking place here you're a man you're
not prepared for what's to come and then
essentially this kind of whisks him away
and calls it a day and that's that's
that's really it here so again going
through these files and doing some some
investigations you know really eight
hours until the present day um in the
middle of blue beetles
you know I guess following his being
teleported away of course this ship is
destroyed and what it does is it leads
to him being taken up or taken aboard
the Justice League Watchtower now again
this is where he runs into Wonder Woman
and that's the other cool thing about
this is because with the character of
Wonder Woman the riders tend to ride her
in a way to where she's either a warrior
or she's a woman she's never both the
great thing about the story is that we
kind of get both aspects of her in the
sense that she's very calm she's very
welcoming she has a very warm
personality she's not just like blog
let's go destroy stuff like I mean she's
not really like that in this particular
story and even Blue Beetle in the
context of the events comments on that
that whenever Wonder Woman says
someone's name when she speaks to them
it's like she knows everything about
your life and what this is designed to
do is kind of build off the work that's
been done with Diana Prince to kind of
remind us that she is a character who is
a warrior in every sense of the word
that she could probably kill Superman if
it came down to it but in the presence
of friends and the presence of people
that she's familiar with she's a friend
she's someone that you can count on
someone you can rely on it was a great
way to give us you know both sides of
who she is in terms of creating a
cohesive character for her the problem
with this is that you know where she
basically says you know hey keep me
abreast of your investigation let me
know what's going on you know keep
detailed files it really seems to be
more placation than anything else like
yeah sure I believe you I mean I trust
you man it's okay just you know keep me
aware heat me you know make sure I'm
informed that kind of thing but she
doesn't really do anything to like go
with him and help his investigation this
is compounded by the fact that his
Booster Gold is making his way out of
the Justice League Watchtower he comes
across Martian Manhunter Jon Jones and
John Jones response is hey look Wonder
Woman said that she may trust you that
she may believe you but she's really a
lot more trusting than she should be any
superhero with their salt is going to
believe that you're just full of crap
beard is going on about
nonsense and so again it's not really
John Jones trying to be cruel it's not
him trying to be rude it's him just kind
of running over the fact of the
situation because again Martian
Manhunter is very kind of like hey
here's how things are like I don't have
time to worry about your feelings here
is the fact of the situation and that's
really the naked truth and naked truth
here is that a majority of the
superheroes out there do not consider
Blue Beetle to be anyone of any real
serious note and what this is designed
to do is kind of reflect the existing DC
community right if I go out into a
street and I show people a picture of
Batman I'm gonna say who is that they're
gonna say well it's Batman if I show him
a picture of Superman they'll say that's
Superman Wonder Woman the flash so on
and so forth if I show them a picture of
Blue Beetle they're not gonna have a
clue who that is I don't know is that
blue guy that is you know they're not
gonna know who he is the fact that he's
obscure to really the the public at
large the non-colored book-reading
community at large is a reflection of
how he's viewed by the superhero
community the superhero community
doesn't take him seriously he's a
small-time guy he's a second-stringer
you call Blue Beetle and when everybody
else is dead when there's no one left to
fight you just bring him off the bench
and say hey man you got to get in there
and you got to put up the good fight you
know people of general public view him
the exact same way now Blue Beetle fans
will hit the roof if you tell them that
Blue Beetle sucks walk out to a Blue
Beetle fan and say hey I was reading
about Blue Beetle recently I gotta say
man that guy's sucks they won't freak
that will lose their absolute mind like
he's got a small fanbase I think amazing
zero we were talking about this in the
discord he was like Blue Beetle has a
small fan base but it is a hardcore
dedicated fan base it is insane
but you know as he's kind of going
through you know backwards home used to
be and he's kind of going through this
this whole this whole issue kind of
struggling and trying to figure out his
place and you know really asking the
question am I really just going on a
wild goose chase
am I just a dog chasing its tail he
didn't begins to realize that somebody's
watching him and the reason why is
because he basically discovered what
amounts to a small little camera or
small little monitoring device inside
the goggles of his helmet and so what he
does is he races off to Booster Gold
tells him what's going on you know Bruce
Segal tries to help of course with him
sustaining injury he can't really go but
Booster Gold basically collapses from
his injuries from the pain he's
experiencing he's put back to sleep by
the nurses and then Blue Beetle tells
the nurse he says hey look you have to
promise me something tell Booster Gold
no matter what happens it's not his
fault that he's the best friend that
Blue Beetle
has ever had and so this basically leads
into the ending of the story and it
picks up with a Blue Beetle following or
I guess arriving a checkmate which
really kind of brings us back to the
beginning of the story now with regards
to him going through this database and
going through all this information what
happens is we end up finding out the
hidden hand behind all these things that
have been happening is Maxwell Lord and
what ended up happening is that when
Batman created brother I it was designed
really with like the best in tendons or
at least the best intentions in terms of
like Batman right I mean Batman's not
like it's not like a like an altruistic
guy Batman's like hey look I really care
about your thoughts and feelings that's
pretty far from that but what ended up
happening here is that the checkmate
organization which was previously kind
of a branch off of the u.s. cover where
it operated on behalf of the US
government and carrying out a really
kind of serving as like a monitoring arm
was relaunched and retooled by Maxwell
Lord for the purpose of hijacking
brother I and using brother I as a means
to monitor superheroes around the world
and so what Maxwell Lord wanted to do is
basically say hey look there's like 90 L
with of all the superhero I guess all
the super-powered people out there you
know the 1.9 million people out there
who have powers 95% of them are nuisance
powers meaning that you know they can
barely use their telekinesis or they can
kind of read surface thoughts or maybe
they can teleport a little bit or
something like that they can't do
anything outrageous but there's the 5%
that can do insane things who can fly
who are invulnerable who have
super-strength SuperSpeed you know who
are a credible threat to any country
they come across not just a group of
people but a country and Maxwell Lords
idea is to basically say we're not going
to allow our world to be ran by people
with superpowers we're going to allow
our world to be rant by humans and we're
going to control superheroes now this is
not Maxwell Lord doing this for the
purpose of just saying we really need a
great safe world where superheroes are
under control this is a power-hungry
Maxwell Lord he's looking to use
checkmater really his brother I and
Project Omak is a way to basically
control the world I mean that's really
what this is this is kind of world
domination if you control Superman if
you control Wonder Woman if you control
the Green Lantern the flash Aquaman so
on and so forth you control the future
of the planet because all you have to do
is send the Justice League into a
country and that country doesn't exist
anymore and so because of that Maxwell
Lord basically gives Blue Beetle a
choice he says look you can
join me in this crusade you can join me
in this task or you can stand against me
if you stand against me you are going to
die now what he also does is he /
basically deploys one of his Oh max
these super powerful beings they're
designed to really kind of counter the
various powers of different individuals
out there those of you guys who are
familiar however I mean people who are
but for those are guys who were familiar
with like the old-school Marvel UK
Captain Britain stuff think of this as
like a kind of DC version of the fury I
mean it's not intrinsic in the sense of
like the fury was designed to counter
every single superpower but you guys
understand what I'm saying in this sense
it was kind of like you know this this
force of some kind but the fact remains
here that because of the fact that Blue
Beetle chooses not to ally himself with
Maxwell Lord Maxwell Lord shoots him in
the head just kills Blue Beetle on the
spot and that's the death of Ted Kord
now what this does is it sets the stage
for later on down the line which leads
into the events of Infinite Crisis the
reason being is because the world is
becoming a darker place now on the
surface it does not seem like this has
anything to do with Infinite Crisis and
I understand that in its entirety
however the darker nature of these
stories because you'll notice these
stories are dark these stories are
gritty these stories are not designed to
be happy and fluffy they're in stark
contrast to what you're seeing in DC
rebirth right now the nature of the
superhero community in the world at this
moment in DC Comics with regards to this
countdown to Infinite Crisis is the
reason why superboy-prime why it is that
earth 3 lex luthor and earth to Superman
and Lois Lane show up in the world in
the first place is because to them the
world's darker these are not superheroes
these are people who used to be
superheroes but they're basically
villains now there's no real difference
between villains and heroes
okay so as we get into Infinite Crisis
or really not invert across as official
as we sort of get into it I'm gonna go
ahead and roll this in as part of
Infinite Crisis where it's gonna sort of
title it this way remember we're
covering Infinite Crisis because of the
fact that this really gives a
superboy-prime and it lays the
groundwork for what happens with regards
to like the Jeff Jones Green Lantern
line of stories going into like Sinestro
Corps war and all that kind of good
stuff plus is just a story that I've
really felt like doing but I figure if
I'm gonna do Infinite Crisis like we're
gonna we're gonna go for broke we're
gonna do it all we're really gonna swing
for the fences here and we'll pick up
with what's called the Omak project now
the Omak project is essentially
explained to us over the course of this
particular storm what we end up doing
here is we actually pick up with a girl
named Sasha Bordeaux now Sasha it was
one of these characters who's relatively
new or is really who is new relative to
the creation of this story so she
appeared in Detective Comics 751 I think
it was in 2000 and she was one of those
characters that DC brought in and then
just didn't really know what to do with
it I mean was one of those weird
situations because at the time DC was
toying with the notion of like Batman
for having a love interest and that's
kind of been an on again off the end
thing it's always been the idea that
maybe Bruce Wayne will find love and he
won't be so mean and brooding and so on
and so forth but people love the the
mean and brooding Batman they love that
version of his character and so because
of that Sasha was shuffled out pretty
fast in the in the sense that she was
basically had a world over into
checkmate now at the time checkmate was
essentially a governmental organization
that was similar but a little bit
different from Marvel's Hellfire Club in
the sense that were Marvel's Hellfire
Club exists behind the scenes to more or
less try to influence and take over the
world
checkmate does not serve that purpose
but they are similar in the sense that
their ranks are modeled after chess
pieces black kings black Queens white
Kings white Queens so on and so forth
now of course with much like really much
like the Hellfire Club the black King is
like the top person and in checkmate and
of course right now in this story the
black King is is Maxwell Lord but this
story takes place immediately after the
death of Blue Beetle and so Sasha
alongside a handful of others are
basically tasked with taking Blue Beetle
away now because of the fact that Sasha
had spent some time alongside Bruce
Wayne because she had basically been his
bodyguard because she had been the one
to deduce his identity after basically
you know poking around and noticing how
often Bruce Wayne was staying out late
at night and suddenly putting two and
two together
the idea eventually came to her that as
part of checkmate she wasn't really
rank-and-file which is to say she didn't
believe wholeheartedly in their ideals
but there was a measure of loyalty in
the sense that her life was basically on
the verge of being lost and checkmate
brought her back from the brink of death
and so because of that she had a loyalty
to the organization but under the
direction of Maxwell Lord
checkmate had become a far more sinister
organization now the other half of this
is that Maxwell Lord had basically come
into control of something called brother
it really was like brother Mark one now
we're gonna refer to it as brother 1 for
the time being but the fact remains that
Maxwell Lord had come into control of
this and what ends up happening here is
Maxwell Lord basically just begins using
brother 1 for the purpose of monitoring
all the superheroes across the world
specifically monitoring the members of
the Justice League now the reason why
this happened was because of the fact
that Maxwell Lord you know killing Ted
Kord came to the realization that if Ted
knew about about Maxwell Lord what he
was getting up to what he was doing then
it also meant that somebody else would
eventually figure out what was going on
now the other half of this is that Ted
Kord the Blue Beetle had basically
eradicated almost all of the files that
brother 1 had on the different
metahumans that existed because remember
Maxwell Lord wanted to keep an eye on
metahumans and basically keep them under
his control now in Ted Kord destroyed
those files the only ones that were left
behind were the Oh Mac project files so
because of that it still leaves the Oh
Mac project intact we'll find out more
about that as we get towards the end of
this story but really this is just a
matter of hymn of Maxwell Lord keeping
an eye on the members of the Justice
League as well as other people who have
associated with with Blue Beetle whether
they were friends or enemies regardless
of their stance now what this also does
is it coincides with Batman trying to
figure out what's going on with brother
1 due to the fact that he doesn't have
control of it anymore remember Batman
made rather one for the purpose of
keeping an eye on metahumans after the
events of really the events of identity
crisis so because of the fact the Batman
came to the belief that metahumans
couldn't be trusted that they had to be
monitored brother 1 served the purpose
of just keeping an eye on them the
problem is that with Maxwell Lord taking
over brother 1 what he's done is
basically removed brother 1 away from
Bruce Wayne and now has total control
over it and so because of that things
progress exactly the way we would expect
him to but it also picks up with Wonder
Woman and Booster Gold not keep him on
Booster Gold and Ted Kord were extremely
close friends and of all the people who
were
on Ted Kord side you know Booster Gold
was really the only one that generally
that that genuinely actually believed
him now of course one everyone believed
him to a degree but what this does is it
shows us the fallout of what happens
when a member of the Justice League dies
because no one else believed them
something else to also point out here is
that Blue Beetle himself was not really
a part of the Justice League per se he
was part of Justice League International
which was kind of like a branch off team
I will actually see that group reform to
a degree not nearly as big as it was
before but to a degree with regards to
them calling in their own group of
people in response to the to the death
of Blue Beetle
so what is up happening here as we pick
up with with Sasha when she's basically
sent on a mission by Maxwell Lord but
what she does is she takes the goggles
of Blue Beetle and she mails them to
Bruce Wayne now of course the crazy
thing about this is that when when
Alfred comes downstairs and initially
goes to give Batman the package he kind
of blows it off because in his mind the
biggest concern is why is he going to do
when the world finds out that he no
longer has control of a massive orbital
satellite system designed to monitor
metahumans what's gonna happen when the
Justice League realizes that he doesn't
control that anymore more so than that
what happens if the person who does
control it decides to use it for
nefarious purposes and so because of
this he's basically just kind of hounded
by Alfred and eventually opens up the
Box only to realize that it came from
Sasha and when Sasha basically says you
don't control brother I anymore it's
also met with the goggles of Blue Beetle
which is Batman basically learning that
Blue Beetle has been killed and so what
happens is of course the most likely
scenario the most likely fallout when
Batman goes to visit the rest of the
Justice League and tells them what's
going on now of course Booster Gold
freaks out and the reason why is because
Booster Gold says look this is your
fault Blue Beetle came to you and said
there's something going on here
somebody's doing something behind the
scenes I'm trying to figure out who
broke into my warehouse I'm trying to
figure out what's going on with all this
Batman had a general idea of what was
going on but didn't say anything he
didn't speak up and so when the eyes of
Booster Gold
Batman's refusal to act resulted in blue
beetles death whereas of Batman that's
ho Blue Beetle look here's what I think
is going on let's just go ahead and put
our minds together let's put two and two
together you know combine our resources
and see what we can come to which would
have likely resulted in the rest of the
Justice League etting involved and would
have seen the survival of Blue Beetle
instead
Batman's refusal to help resulted in the
death of Blue Beetle now the other half
of this is the rest of the Justice
League Wonder Woman was more or less
patronizing when Blue Beetle went to go
see her when he said hey look here's
things going off she said well that's
nice come and see me when you have some
more information she said it the nicest
way possible but she more or less blew
him off Martian Manhunter the exact same
way Superman the exact same way Hal
Jordan all the other superheroes blew
off Ted Kord and assume that he D was
basically going on a wild goose chase of
course he was onto something it resulted
in his death and so they're all
experiencing their own measure of guilt
but the other half of this is that we're
also starting to see infighting among
the Justice League more so than we were
before the Justice League is always kind
of bickered is that we've they've always
argued to a degree and that whole you
know dichotomy between the different
belief systems of all the different
characters it's what makes the Justice
League so interesting because Wonder
Woman's a warrior Superman is the moral
backbone Batman is the detective
everybody has something different to
offer to the team but they all come to
the Justice League with their own
experiences guiding the way they view
the world and so because of that they
bump heads they don't necessarily see
eye to eye 100 percent of the time there
was a time when they did but that was
1960s DC Comics now it's more realistic
it's more grounded and that is a theme
that I want you to keep in the back of
your head as we end up going more into
Infinite Crisis because what we're gonna
find out is the return of Superboy pron
the return of Earth to Superman the
return of Earth 3 Alexander Luthor it's
not altruism they look at the modern-day
superheroes and say you've fallen from
grace you are not who you're supposed to
be and it's really gonna be a Jeff Jones
meta commentary on the state of DC
Comics at the time that this story was
written when he was basically using
Infinite Crisis to say superheroes
should be stories that are uplifting
stories that are cheerful stories that
give people a reason to look to the
sunrise not stories that are dark and
are brooding and make everybody feel
miserable about their lives this should
be a welcome escape not so many people
feel like they gotta have to read and
darkness that ends up following their
path but regarding this story you know
regarding the events that are going on
right here with the Omak project with
Sasha coming to the realization that
Maxwell Lord knows that you know Batman
had gotten ahold of these goggles her
idea is that it's only a matter of time
before Maxwell or traces it back to her
and when that happens the question
becomes what goes on next now what this
also does is it basically coincides with
Maxwell Lord having a woman by the name
of Jessica midnight execute the other
members of the checkmate organization
now this is a two-fold step by Maxwell
war the first is to basically impose his
will on those around him to solidify the
fact that he's not someone
be trifled with the second is to
consolidate power unto himself and
that's one of the reasons why Maxwell
Lord was so interesting is because when
you look at him there were a lot of
allegories to like you know Hitler for
example you know the night of the Long
Knives executing the head of the of the
brown brown shirts Browncoats whatever
they worked you know executing all those
guys and then consolidating power under
the Nazi Party at the same time Maxwell
Lord does something similar now it's not
to say that Maxwell Lord and Hitler are
the same thing what Hitler did is
something that's been seen time and time
again by ruling people it's it's not
uncommon it's not uncommon for someone
to go in to have allies in order to help
themselves you know take some measure of
power and then kill their allies and
usurp their territory that's not an
uncommon thing that's happened all
throughout history and what DC does is
Maxwell Lord is they take that exact
same concept and roll it in here now of
course the way that Maxwell Lord does
this is by virtue of his ability to
dominate the minds of others now
Maxwell's ability to manipulate Minds is
not like wholesale telepathy right it's
not him just going in and just saying
like I have total control of your mind
it's really more akin to like what the
purple man does in the sense that where
the purple man puts off pheromones and
basically issues commands that people
just can't resist it Maxwell Lord is
much the same way but it's really a lot
of mental control that goes in there the
issue with this is that Maxwell Lords
ability to dominate Minds is contingent
based on the mindset of the person that
he's dominating at the time so a fully
powered Superman 100% cognizant of his
surroundings focusing only on Maxwell
Lord would not be as easy to dominate as
a Superman that we'll see in this story
when he is dominated by the actual Lord
because his focus has caught him in
different places at the same time he's
in a relatively weakened state in terms
of where his mind's at but the fact
remains here that under the control of
Maxwell Lord Jessica midnight kills all
these different heads of the houses at
the same time Maxwell Lord says now
we're going to frame her for this crime
and this is how Maxwell functioned
that's why he's such a great charismatic
guy that's why a lot of people love his
character is because he's just so cruel
man like he's just so mean the big
lebowski he's just mean man like it's
it's it's crazy how it all comes down
but the fact remains here that this is
really again Sasha's loyalties being
tested to the sense that she doesn't
believe that she can be someone they can
truly ally herself with Maxwell Lord or
his ideologies so what is up happening
here is she basically calls a one-on-one
meeting with Bruce Wayne but what
happens is the entire scenario is seen
by Maxwell Lord now the
when this matters is because of the fact
that by virtue of her act manipulate
Maxwell Lord to make him believe what
she wants to believe just by virtue of
engineering circumstances in her favor
Maxwell Lord had no reason to believe
that sasha bordo was against him but
with this revelation he now knows that
she is so what happens is we start
seeing the implementation of these Oh
max now the Oh max that I want to kind
of wait until we got to this section to
basically run over this the Oh max are
basically cyborgs but they're inherently
human and what happened is that
somewhere along the line basically
individuals started having nano machines
planted inside their bodies without them
knowing it so what would happen is under
the direction of Maxwell Lord by
activating you know the Omak protocol
these individuals their nano machines
would effectively manifest they would
take on a cyborg form and then they
would just operate according to whatever
it is that Maxwell Lord tells them to do
through the brother one system and so
because that you know when these
individuals become Oh max they have no
self will they have no free will no self
determination they simply do as they're
told
so what happens is of course you know
sasha is basically taken by Maxwell Lord
and then Batman fins off as best he can
but of course against these Oh max
Batman can only do so much and so of
course he's rescued by Superman and
that's really that but at this point is
basically everybody kind of rallying
around this idea that Blue Beetle had
died and how they're reacting to it
specifically with the return of Guy
Gardner now remember because of the fact
that Booster Gold and Blue Beetle along
with a handful of the other minor
superheroes all served on Justice League
international they basically formed a
kind of brotherhood of sorts in the
sense that whenever one of them is in
danger they will all respond if at all
possible and so because of this with the
death of Blue Beetle Guy Gardner's
response alongside Booster Gold is we
have to go find out who it was that
killed them more so than that they
actually tell Wonder Woman to stay out
of it and the reason why is because in
their mind they're like you're part of
that Justice League you're not part of
our Justice League now this is a in
comic kind of allegory for the way the
fans view the Justice League at one
point in time and the reason why is
because remember after crisis on
Infinite Earths there was no traditional
Justice League Batman Superman Wonder
Woman the flash Green Lantern so on and
so forth there was Justice League
International it wasn't until 1998 some
thirteen years after the events of
crisis on Infinite Earths that we got
the return of the Justice League as we
new them but the idea here was that the
members of Justice League International
were basically their own group and so
because that there were essentially two
factions of the Justice League
running around even if one of them
wasn't official and so what it did is it
basically kind of created a rift in the
sense that they didn't really see
themselves eye to eye they didn't really
see themselves as equal it was really
like that's your team this is my team
you stay away I stay away and everything
will be okay now yet they work together
in times of extreme duress but on the
whole they really saw themselves as
their own individual teams and so
because of this you know this is really
just the revelation you know kind of
coming to fruition the revelation
continuing that everybody is essentially
going after whoever it was that was
behind the murder of Blue Beetle of
course we know that to be Maxwell Lord
the other problem with this is that with
Maxwell Lord using using brother one to
spy on the Justice League inside the
watchtower he comes to the realization
that Batman is effectively spilling the
beans on everything he knows behind the
events of brother one and the whole nine
yards and so because of this Maxwell
Lord essentially jumps the gun and says
if I can't take out Batman here then I
will take over someone who can take out
Batman
and this is when he basically begins to
use his ability to take over the mind of
Superman that's why I say if it were
Superman in the height of combat
strictly focusing on Maxwell Lord
Maxwell Lord probably would not be able
to dominate his mind with Superman
operating as Clark Kent with his guard
effectively down Maxwell Lord is able to
overtake him now the problem with this a
little bit of a story here is that I
wasn't able to find her I wasn't able to
get my hands on the comic where Superman
is operating under the control of
Maxwell Lord actually wasn't able to get
my hands on that I was so we kind of
have to jump to like Wonder Woman number
219 but all that really happened in that
story was that Superman had basically
gone after Batman and tried to kill him
under the control of Maxwell Lord but
Wonder Woman intervened and so because
of that we basically pick up with Wonder
Woman as part of this equation now of
course
Wonder Woman fighting fighting against
Superman is actually a pretty cool
battle and the reason why is because
it's again DC sort of reiterating this
idea that when it really comes down to
it Wonder Woman is every bit Superman's
equal if not a little more superior and
the reason why is because of the fact
that when a woman is a warrior
whereas Superman is more of a protector
and so because of that their ideologies
their moral compasses really fly in the
face of what we would consider to be an
actual battle between the two in terms
of who
actually went now one thing to also keep
in mind is that Superman is fighting
with the extent of his powers here and
that's why I say this battle is so
interesting is because right now in this
moment Superman's not holding back this
is a fight presumably to the death now
Wonder Woman tries to keep him alive as
best she can just because the fact that
she's aware the Superman is not in
control of his full faculties but the
fact remains here that when it comes to
a legit fight between the two of them
they're both able to hold their own
against one another and Wonder will
improve yourself to be really formidable
against him and so I think it was kind
of a cool thing that should be mentioned
here just because of the fact that when
we talk about superheroes the Wonder
Woman is really like the first woman of
comics the first lady of comics in
superhero form and when we're talking
about just like you know the
quintessential women in comics that
title goes to Lois Lane in my book but
in terms of you know powerful women and
major roles one of them is really at the
cream of the crop when it comes to that
and so because of this you know with
Superman more or less subdued at least
temporarily Wonder Woman Ratz Maxwell
Lord around with a lasso of truth and
says tell me how to relinquish Superman
from your control Maxwell Lord responds
by simply saying kill me and that's
exactly what Wonder Woman does she snaps
his neck so for those of you guys who
have seen that now famous panel where
when a woman kills Maxwell Lord you've
probably seen it and like the most
insane you know comic book deaths of all
time or something like that are like the
craziest Wonder Woman moments usually
see those kind of clickbait nonsensical
things on BuzzFeed but if you've seen
those you know in anticipation of the
Wonder Woman movie this is where that
comes from this is why that happens
because Maxwell Lord literally says the
once I take control of a person they're
not free unless I want them to be free
or unless I die now this is really where
the rift in the Justice League comes
into play the reason why I say that is
because within the Justice League
themselves you know even within you know
like Superman's mantra killing is a
no-no the only time it's okay to kill is
if there's absolutely no other choice
now in the eyes of Wonder Woman
there was no other choice it was the
only way to free Superman from Maxwell
Lords control but that's not necessarily
true
Wonder Woman could have knocked him out
Wonder Woman could have knocked out both
Superman and Maxwell Lord taking them
back to the watchtower or taking them
back to earth and then turn around and
said okay look you know we have to find
some way to reverse this there were
different roads that could have been
taken according to Superman but in
Wonder Woman's mind that was not the
case she was thinking in the moment not
only
that it was also a little bit of revenge
she looked at this and said this is the
man that killed Blue Beetle now I would
go as far as to say that Wonder Woman
was making up for what she perceived to
be her failure as a superhero in the
moment of truth when Blue Beetle came to
her and said I need your help she wasn't
there to help him and so in a lot of
ways I would consider this to be as a
scenario that plays out where she
basically says hey look you know this
seems to be me just kind of helping him
out making amends for the fact that I
wasn't there when he needed me basically
getting vengeance the problem with this
is that with the death of Maxwell Lord
the king is dead program is activated
and brother Wan basically transforms
himself into brother eye and becomes
fully autonomous now we don't initially
know this is the case and in fact as the
reader and the only thing that we have
to believe is that there was some kind
of failsafe program that was activated
that for whatever reason are in some
form or fashion that brother Wan was
basically monitoring the vital signs of
of Maxwell Lord and with Maxwell Lord
dying that the program was then
activated but in fact we're actually
gonna learn that's not the case but
switching back over to Sasha bordo and
Jessica midnight because of the fact
that Jessica midnight was being held
prisoner after being framed by a Maxwell
Lord or really being forced by an actual
Lord to kill those members of checkmate
as well as Sasha bordo who was caught
red-handed leaking information a Batman
the two of them basically engineered
their escape and this is when DC begins
the process of sort of offering some new
standing for the character of Sasha
Bordeaux and the reason why is because
she begins to show indications that she
herself is an omec remember when a
person becomes an omec they don't know
they've been infected with those those
nanobots you know they're they're
basically lose all sense of
individuality and they effectively black
out I mean it's almost like just chunks
of their memory are gone you know and
then maybe they go back to being their
normal selves maybe they never go back
and they stay Oh max forever but the
fact remains here that with Batman
recovering from his injuries after
sustaining a pretty heavy beating from
Superman one is up happening here is he
begins talking with brother 1 and what
brother 1 says or I guess brother I now
what he basically says is that it was
created by Batman for the purpose of
monitoring superhumans and to basically
catalog information but under the
control of Maxwell Lord the programming
of brother brother I was modified to
basically view superhumans as an
inherent threat to earth but to operate
under the direction of Maxwell Lord with
Maxwell Lord having been killed brother
I did the next best thing the only thing
it really knew how to do
it made itself fully autonomous it
merged the programming of Bruce Wayne
and Maxwell work together and basically
said I now exist for the purpose of
tracking all metahumans on earth and
then killing them all and so what this
does is it basically sets in motion this
massive releases massive activation of
all these Omax
across the world so for those of you
guys who jumped directly into Infinite
Crisis and those are the guys who are
curious as to why you see all these
giant robots flying around and attacking
everybody this is the reason why because
brother I basically activated the Omak
protocol and what it did is it sent all
these really you know activated all
these different Oh match now in terms of
how many there actually are we're not
given that information right off the bat
instead we actually end up having you
know the death of a few superheroes here
and there rocket red 7 now when it comes
to the rocket reds and they were created
for the purpose of being the ussr's own
superhero team you know strictly for
their for their own country the issue
with this is that with the Omax being
activated superhero groups from across
the world who would normally never
interact are now banding together but
the other reason for this is because of
the fact that rocket red has a lot of
dealings with conventional superheroes
as we know them operating out of out of
the united states so because of this the
old rocket red basically tells Guy
Gardner put one of your shields around
me rocket red then activates his ability
to create you know all kinds of energy
projections and basically blows up the
entire area inside this bubble killing
himself
as well as these different different Oh
max but at this point this is when we
basically learned Sasha Bordeaux herself
is an omec the reason we learned this is
because of the fact that her body is
undergoing the physical change when the
nano machines activate but the
difference is that she's not like all
the other Oh max she maintains her own
individuality now the reason why she
maintains her individuality is because
she was not subjected to the same
process that all the other Oh max were
subjected to when they were given their
nanobots instead she was a unique
creation really created by Maxwell Lord
himself and the reason why was because
Maxwell Lord wanted a fail-safe Maxwell
word wanted to know that if things went
awry that he would basically have
somebody who was loyal to him with
absolute certainty and would have all
the powers of a nomad but of course with
Maxwell Lord being dead and Sasha
bordello having turned against him
anyway
once her nanobots began to activate she
basically has all the powers of an omec
but she's self-aware she's not tied into
the control of brother eyes so she's not
forced
the bidding of others now at this point
this is when she contacts Bruce Wayne
and says look you have to round up all
those superheroes as best you can we
have to find a way to basically fight
off her or basically destroy brother I
and when Batman's response is why she
basically says because brother eye is
activating them now when Batman asks
them what are you talking about she says
the O match that there's one 1.3 million
of them and so because of that there's 1
million Samad own acts running around
the planet earth and they've all been
tasked with the purpose of killing
metahumans it's really just things
popping off in the extreme degree and so
what is up happening here is Batman
really kind of makes this last-ditch
effort that's one of the reasons why
this is kind of cool and one of the
reasons why we really had to do
countdown to Infinite Crisis the reason
why is because of the fact that in that
story we had seen it somebody had broken
into the warehouse of Blue Beetle
somebody had stolen you know a ton of
kryptonite but we never found out where
the Kryptonite went this is when Batman
starts putting two and two together and
this is why this is such kind of a you
know really a tragic moment in the story
because Batman figured out what was
happening right off the bat as soon as
you was in the warehouse and he started
looking around he immediately figured
out what was going on if he had put his
mind to tasks when this all first
started Blue Beetle would have been
alive but what Batman says is that
within this particular warehouse was
basically a giant EMP machine that Blue
Beetle had made that would set off an
EMP in a pretty large location now of
course the only way to really take out
every single Omak across the world is to
detonate an EMP that's equivalent to a
15 Megaton nuclear bomb well the issue
is it would kill everybody in range if
it would literally just kind of blink
out the electrical impulses in their
brains everybody would just die and so
because of that the idea is to basically
confine all these different Lmax into a
singular location using a massive
massive number of superheroes as a
beacon as bait and so a Batman basically
draws on Hal Jordan and John Stewart and
says grab as many heroes as you can go
to this mountain out in the middle of
nowhere and then draw the lomax to you
when that happens we're going to
activate this EMP and we're gonna try to
take them all out the problem with this
is that Batman is actually too little
too late now none of those heroes die
instead it all really comes down to
Sasha and what is up happening is that
with with all these Oh max basically
just bearing down on them descending on
all these different superheroes that one
is up happening is Sasha actually hacks
into brother I directly and what she
does is she distributes a virus that
basis
we begins to shut down the connection
between the nanobots in the in the Oh
max and brother I itself now of course
it doesn't mean that all the Oh max are
destroyed and in fact some 200,000
managed to continue existing but the big
drop in this story the the huge
revelation that really came out of the o
Mac project was that with the conclusion
of this we end up finding out that
brother I had actually taken the footage
of Wonder Woman killing Maxwell Lord and
broadcast it out to the world and that
is a huge event that comes out of this
that's why the story is important for
Infinite Crisis and that's why it
creates a rift in the superhero
community because of the fact that the
world now sees Wonder Woman committing
murder okay man we are here man is
something wrong core man Jason now and
for the crisis superboy-prime man fight
everyone did it is that's why I titled
this superboy-prime versus everyone
because that's exactly what it is and he
wrecks everyone it's the coolest thing
it's like the coolest thing ever I
understand is this what I've been
missing is this what I've been missing
with DC Comics like let's get into this
alright cuz I'm I'm getting hyped up as
it is alright before we start this what
I want to do is I want to flesh out the
multiversal concept in the realm of DC
Comics oh so here's the deal alright
those of you guys who are familiar with
this bear with me for a second but even
now it's still kind of baffles people a
little bit alright in the history of DC
Comics there's been two multiverses I
mean Grant Morrison does his own thing
but we're gonna leave Grant Morrison out
of this equation there's been two
different iterations of the multiverse
the first one is the one that was
destroyed with crisis on Infinite Earths
the second one is the one that comes
back because of this story Infinite
Crisis so this actually makes a new
multiverse new histories different
things like that but the fact remains
here that we don't need to go into a
great big huge explanation about crisis
on Infinite Earths we know about that
story I've done a video on it we have
the origin of superboy-prime that kind
of helps us to tie into it a little bit
but what ended up happening here is it
essentially the multiverse collapse so
it was the end of all things with
regards to the DC universe and what came
after that was one singular universe so
everything that happened in DC Comics
between the end of
is on Infinite Earths in 1985 and right
now in the beginning of this story has
all taken place in one singular universe
called new earth that's what that whole
phrase comes from now with regards to
the characters that we're gonna see here
superboy-prime earth to Superman earth
to Lois Lane earth 3 Alexander Luthor we
don't really have to worry about like
earth 3 and different things like that
all we have to know is that during the
events of crisis on Infinite Earths when
the multiverse was collapsing because of
the fact that all these different
universes were impacted the superheroes
just ran around grabbing who they could
when they could and then brought them
into the fold to fight against the
anti-monitor the result was that because
DC wanted to basically revamp the
Superman mythos and return Superman to
being the sole survivor of Krypton with
no other versions of himself out there
what they did is they said ok at the end
of crisis on Infinite Earths Superman
from Earth 2 which is basically the
1930s 1940s Superman Lois Lane from
Earth 2 from that same point in time
1930s 1940s and Alexander Luthor who's
basically the son of Lex Luthor from
earth 3 who was a good guy
they're gonna be shunted off to the
Paradise dimension now DC's in tension
with crisis on Infinite Earths was to
never use them again who is to basically
write them out of the story and the
Paradise I mentioned was effectively
heaven that's really what it was it was
their own little realm their own little
place it was heaven and they were never
gonna be seen or heard from again now
cue the post-crisis landscape because of
stories like the death of Gwen Stacy in
1971 comic books were moving towards
this trend of becoming darker in the xix
age I think was 1986 1987 something like
that weeded up getting Batman The Dark
Knight Returns we got Batman The Killing
Joke and between those stories comic
books began to become darker and more
realistic and more of a reflection of
the cynical nature of the real world now
with regards to this story
what geoff johns is doing is basically
issuing a meta commentary but there are
a handful of things that led up to this
because it wasn't like Infinite Crisis
just dropped out of nowhere like there
were things that were going on that
we're leading up to this in JLA Justice
League of America number 118 119 and 120
what ended up happening is the Justice
League was going against various forces
that seemed to just kind of be there
there were just you know random
individuals for the Justice League to
fight but in the middle of all that
Martian Manhunter was just suddenly
kidnapped
and the entire Justice League Watchtower
was completely obliterated now what we
also have is the O mat project that
sword where we talked about Batman's
whole Omak thing and all those different
robots and so on and so forth we're just
kind of activating throughout the world
with the intention of annihilating
metahumans all these things begin to
converge into the start of Infinite
Crisis now there's a handful of other
things too but we'll cross that bridge
when we get to it we're gonna go ahead
and jump directly into this so of course
this comes as fallout of the destruction
of the Justice League Watchtower but
also the revelation from the rest of the
Justice League that Batman had created
the OMAP project because of that the
Omak project was basically hijacked by
Maxwell Lord its entire purpose was
corrupted and it became an evil entity
and so the result is that trust in the
Justice League is almost completely
obliterated keep in mind we also saw
Wonder Woman kill Maxwell Lord and so
because that because of the fact that
Maxwell Lord was killed about what this
does or at least what this did is it
resulted in the entire superhero
community and the world basically going
at odds as one another
humanity looked at superheroes as
dangerous people now super heroes the
Justice League couldn't trust each other
and so because of this what it does is
it switches over to Conner Kent now
Conner Kent as he exists here Jesus as
he exists here there we go Cannell he's
a holdover from the Death of Superman
remember when Superman died in 1980 to
1993 DC released four new versions of
him there was the Eradicator there was
cyborg there was basically the
metropolis kid and then there was John
Henry irons also known as steel who just
had a giant steel Superman suit he
didn't actually have any powers or
anything but once Superman came back DC
didn't really know what to do with these
different versions of the characters so
someone away some just kind of vanished
never to be seen or heard from again
but Conner Kent was one of the most
popular and so what ended up happening
is DC just started shunting him off to
like teen books Young Justice you know
Titans Teen Titans that kind of thing
and because of that his character still
maintained you know face value still
maintained publication in the realm of
DC and relevance in the eyes of fans it
was just the idea of him going back to
the way he was in the 1990s was
effectively gone now the other half of
this equation is that Conner Kent has
basically walked away from being a
superhero and the reason why is because
there Kim point when he was essentially
taken over by Lex Luthor and the result
was that he was basically forced to
fight his teammates up once he had
regained his
and he had come back to his normal self
he essentially walked away now the
reason why this is significant is
because of the fact that Connor Kent is
being watched by several individuals
that we can't see who are also watching
a multitude of events unfold all across
the face of the earth and because of all
these different conflicts because of all
these different skirmishes because
Conner Kent does not want to be Superboy
is not going to act as Superboy because
of the fact that Batman's Omak project
is basically run amok what this is done
is it has led these individuals to
believe that these people these
superheroes on earth are not superheroes
they're not acting the way superheroes
should and so because of that in their
mind something needs to be corrected
something basically needs to happen to
fix this problem now at this point we
switch over to the specter now this is
small but this is something that I
actually wanted to toss in here just for
the sake of showing you guys how much
lead um you know how big the whole
Infinite Crisis thing was if you guys
remember our video where we talked about
Green Lantern rebirth and the idea that
Hal Jordan had basically left his role
as the spectre or was really freed from
his role as the spectre and went back to
being Hal Jordan as we knew him an Air
Force pilot aurélia a test pilot
eventually going back into the Green
Lantern Corps again what this did is it
left the spectre without a host know
with the spectre not having a host it
was already on the verge of insanity and
began to sort of dip over and so because
of this the spectre was manipulated by
being called a Calypso which is
basically like the representation of
God's wrath and the DC Universe but what
it did is it sent the spectre on this
absolute rampage the reason being
because the spectre operates as the you
know the the extension of God's judgment
you know it operates as is God's
judgment in the realm of DC Comics and
so because of this Eclipse so it
basically approach the spectre and said
hey look everything exists according to
like the rules according to like the the
law of God
magic violates that law because it
allows people to operate outside of
God's control and because of that these
individuals are basically breaking God's
law the spectre responded by killing the
wizard Shazam the being that basically
gives Billy Batson his powers and
because of this Billy Batson
more-or-less crash labs on earth stating
to everybody Shazam's come been
completely obliterated Shazam is now
dead now again the reason why a lot of
this stuff is done is because of the
fact that this serves the purpose of
allowing DC to go forward after Infinite
Crisis treating it as a soft reboot in
the sense that not everybody gets
rebooted their their histories are
completely
but it basically kind of allows DC to
half way hit the reset switch and kind
of you know offer some new information
or basically change people's histories a
little bit especially with the return of
the multiverses so switching back over
to the to the Justice League Watchtower
again this is pretty small it's not the
most important thing in the world but
it's basically just the arrival of
mongol now again this is Mongols Sun so
because this man was more or less just
kind of relishing in the idea that the
Justice League has been you know been
defeated more or less that they have no
trust in one another because remember
Mom was one of the most formidable foes
of the Justice League in general and
alongside cyborg Superman had eradicated
ko City which set Hal Jordan on the path
of declaring himself as parallax and
becoming a bad guy and during the events
of zero our crisis and time and so
because of this again it's really just
kind of a reminder of how dark things
are simply due to the fact that in the
midst of this conflict Wonder Woman goes
to kill Mongol now one of the things you
may notice here is that this comic this
story as it starts is very dark it's a
very very dark story it's designed to be
that way Geoff Johns wrote this
explicitly and the reason why is because
of the fact that it's no secret Geoff
Johns Harkins for an age when Kiley
books were a lot more lighthearted you
know especially with what we're seeing
right now with like the Superman comics
in DC rebirth Geoff Johns is really more
of a fan of like the Silver Age of
comics the 1950s 1960s you know going
into the 1970s when the Bronze Age
started the idea for for Geoff Johns was
basically saying there was a time when
superheroes were very light hearted when
superhero stories were fun when they
were upbeat when they lifted you up
instead of making you feel like you've
been pulled down and what geoff johns is
basically doing with this you know by
virtue of talking through superboy-prime
earth to superman so on and so forth
is he's basically saying because of the
fact that comics have become a little
more realistic because of the fact that
comics are a little more visceral and a
little more real the magic has
essentially been lost there is no wow
Superman is someone to look up to you
now it's Superman is dark you know
Wonder Woman's dark that man's dark you
know what we need is a return to
greatness and so it's almost like you
can really go back and look at the
history of Geoff Johns various works and
in DC Comics I'm not gonna run them all
off because there's so many of them you
could look at like you know the flash
you can look at me Oh Green Lantern you
can look at the new 52 Justice League
you can trace all these things that
Geoff Johns has done
way up to the start of Rio BC rebirth
and basically see the point he's making
and see his efforts to return in DC
Comics to more of a uplifting place as
opposed to one that's a little too real
and a little too visceral and so in
response to everything that's going on
what we basically have are these hidden
individuals saying enough is enough this
is it this is done we need to do
something we have to step in and this is
when we learn that this is earth to
Superman superboy-prime Alexander Luthor
and Lois Lane so this is such a really
really cool development because when
this first happened it was like oh my
god it was one of the coolest things
ever to take place in this in this
particular story so because that's what
this does is this allows us to segue for
a second to a story called villains
United now again Villas United was a
six-issue miniseries that was a lead-up
or at least part of the lead-up to
Infinite Crisis but like a lot of the
lead ups it wasn't necessarily the story
itself was intrinsic it was what came
out of the story that was important and
that's one of the reasons why I kind of
skipped over I mean if there was
something in the story that was
significant that was wildly important
then I would say okay we'll go through
the whole thing but we can really just
kind of point to the story itself and
highlight the finer points as opposed to
you run to the entire thing now with
regards to this that with regards to
villains United what this was was
basically Lex Luthor reforming the
secret six now I mean there was like
this super you know the secret society
of super villains and so on so forth but
the secret six was more of like an inner
circle of that particular organization
but it was Lex Luthor leading the group
and basically bringing all these
villains together
for the purpose of attacking the super
heroes and so what was going on in the
lead-up to Infinite Crisis as you had
the Omak project these robots running
around trying to annihilate heroes and
villains and then you had the secret six
trying to annihilate superheroes so
because of this in the middle of this
fight we end up having Power Girl
who's basically met by the arrival of
earth to Superman now harkening back to
the beginning of this video when we
talked about like earth two we talked
about the multiverse and so on and so
forth Power Girl was a character who was
introduced before crisis on Infinite
Earths her character is a direct
reflection of the various struggles DC's
faced with regards to continuity issues
following crisis on Infinite Earths
because of the fact that she was the
cousin of Superman from Earth to when
crisis on Infinite Earths happened what
DC did is they went forward
and treated things like the multiverse
never existed well if the multiverse
never existed according to DC the power
girl was still present after crisis on
Infinite Earths then where did she come
from because Superman is supposed to be
the only survivor of Krypton
there is no Supergirl none of that stuff
and so the question is who is she where
does she come from DC tried to go back
and re explain her origins but it was an
absolute mess it was an absolute
nightmare
and so what Geoff Johns is doing here is
he's basically saying all the nonsense
with origin stories and all that jargon
and all that garbage that came after
crisis on Infinite Earths is being
removed in its entirety what he does by
having earth to Superman meet power girl
is basically take her over to you know
this base of operations were
superboy-prime and alexander luthor
we're all operating out of an earth to
Superman basically recounts the entirety
of crisis on Infinite Earths for Howard
rule now because of the fact that this
information is given to her in
conjunction with physically touching you
know these individuals
what is up happening is her entire
history is restored to her and so she
basically remembers all of her history
by you know after crisis on Infinite
Earths as it was basically geoff johns
again essentially saying the origin of
power girl before crisis on Infinite
Earths is now her origin story that's
now the basis behind her character now
the other half of this is that it's also
her basically realizing she's
reencountering a long-lost cousin the
person that she knew the person that she
trusted the person who effectively
adopted her in a lot of ways treated her
like a daughter and so because of this
this is very a celebratory moment
between the two of them but in the midst
of all this we actually switched back
over to to Batman himself now again this
deals a lot with regards to you know all
these different you know the the old
Matt project and so on and so forth but
his Batman trying to keep things back
under control
Batman trying to basically Corral things
back unto himself and the reason why is
because of the fact that Batman is
nothing if not a man who believes that
he can take on the world and keep it
under control that's one of the reasons
why we like his character so much is
because he is basically the epitome of a
control freak but the way it works
itself out is that in this instance with
brother I and the Omak project Batman
can't stop it Batman can't do it on his
own instead he's going to have to turn
to other people he's gonna have to
return you know turn to other
superheroes individuals who can help
them out and so what is up happening
here is we transition back over to earth
to Superman and
is when we learn the real motivation for
why they're here with earth to Superman
superboy-prime
Alexander Luthor all these guys looking
at the superhero landscape you know
while they were in the Paradise
dimension what they've done is they come
to the realization that these
superheroes are not superheroes and so
the idea is to basically eliminate the
entirety of everybody on this earth
eradicated completely free earth to back
and then resurrect these individuals as
their earth-2 counterparts so
essentially saying we're going to get
rid of you as you exist now and we're
gonna bring you back as better and
happier people now the crazy thing about
this is that Power Girl has loyalty
issues at this point and will actually
see what those loyalty issues are but
for the moment we can kind of get away
with simply saying that she's basically
stuck between the superheroes that she's
fought alongside so much the loyalty she
has to them but addition that the loads
he/she has to earth to Superman and her
desire to see things go back to being
you know a better time to the you know
to see superheroes becoming better
people and so what is up happening here
is that with Batman basically struggling
with the idea that brother AI is the
most colossal failure that he's had in
the sense of the program that he did
that he designed completely ran amok
with Batman
you know harkening back to the death of
Jason Todd with Batman looking at the
death of his parents what he sees is
failure after failure after failure and
the interesting thing about this the way
Geoff Johns rife is is that he's
actually not wrong when it comes to the
character of Bruce Wayne when it comes
to the character of Batman he's had a
lot of successes Dick Grayson was a
great success Barbara Gordon being shot
Batman feels it was a failure on his
behalf The Joker's various schemes all
the people who have died because of the
fact that he simply just didn't kill all
his villains outright Batman considers
those to be failures the death of Jason
Todd Batman's failure again and again
and again when Batman could have stepped
in and done the right thing he always
did the wrong thing in his mind so
because of this he's on the verge of
basically giving up and in fact he goes
as far as to say I wish I could start
over and almost like a like a genie
popping out of a bottle of earth -
Superman arrives on the scene and
basically says I can help you with that
now the funny thing about this is that
Batman's like you're not the Superman
that I know when Superman's like I know
I'm from I'm Superman essentially from
Earth - and so again these two basically
end up having a conversation with one
another and the conversation goes as far
as Earth - Superman basically saying
here's what we're gonna do I mean you
know I come from a totally different
place I come from a universe called
Earth - the universe has long since then
gone but I want to bring it back on my
universe on my earth in Earth two
superheroes were something to aspire to
you know superheroes were something to
celebrate superheroes weren't feared by
society
superheroes didn't consider themselves
to be failures they've made mistakes but
in the end they always ended up doing
the right thing
there was no moral ambiguity there was
no well maybe he's a good guy maybe he's
a bad guy there were no anti-heroes
there was right there was wrong and if
you weren't right you were wrong and
that's the coolest thing about this is
because it's very rigid it's very
structured but in a lot of ways it's
also Geoff Johns kind of pointing at his
own desires and essentially saying that
yes I love the Silver Age of comics but
it may not necessarily be you know
exactly as I remember so again there's a
lot of nostalgia fuel going on in this
particular this particular bit you know
miss Dodger feels you know going on this
little particular bit of a story but
what is up happening here is what we do
is we basically have you know Lex Luthor
meeting Lex Luthor now this seems to
come out of left field but the reason
why this is the case is because of the
fact that during the villains United
story that's one of the reasons why I
wanted to just sort of hold us off
during the villains United story Lex
Luthor as he had basically reformed the
secret six was not Lex Luthor
this was actually Alexander Luthor and
one of the things that we end up finding
out here is that over the course of the
time in which they were watching the
various superheroes from the Paradise
dimension Alexander Luthor in
superboy-prime were leaving the Paradise
dimension and they were showing up
inside the you know the the superhero
landscape in DC Comics and they were
basically setting the stage to give them
justification to go to earth to super in
and say look how bad they are look how
much they're failing those aren't
superheroes we need to fix this and so
because of that what is up happening
here is that with you know Alexander
Luthor confronting Lex Luthor Alexander
Luthor immediately overpowers him and
essentially removes them from the
equation now what geoff johns does is he
starts to show us how these guys are not
necessarily on earth to steal and so on
and so forth how they're not necessarily
the great and magical superheroes that
we remember and this is why I say Geoff
Johns is kind of pointing at his own
case of nostalgia he's kind of pointing
at his own case and saying just because
we remember things a certain way doesn't
mean they are that way and so with earth
to Superman basically approaching Bruce
Wayne he's like look man change is
coming either this change can be easy or
this change can be painful but
just coming it's better to be on the
devil's right hand than in his path and
so because of this Superman you know
earth to Superman basically says look
this is gonna happen we're going to
eliminate you and we're gonna replace
you with something better make it easy
on yourself now of course Batman's
response is to use kryptonite and this
is when Jeff John steps in and basically
sets the stage for how superboy-prime is
going to wreck the world
what is up happening here is earth to
Superman tells Batman that's kryptonite
that earth once Superman gave you but it
doesn't work on me because it's not the
Kryptonite from my universe this is
really interesting this is really cool
for those of you guys who are following
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers this
basically works in the exact same
fashion as the Infinity Gauntlet the
Infinity Gauntlet can only be used in
the universe that the Infinity stones
come from kryptonite can only work on
you know the same universe as a Superman
that it comes from so earth one
Kryptonite works on earth one Superman
earth - kryptonite works on earth two
Superman earth one kryptonite will not
work on earth two Superman now the
reason why this is important is because
as we saw in our video on the origin of
superboy-prime Krypton was obliterated
in its entirety
kryptonite are basically just
radioactive shards of Krypton because of
the fact that that Krypton from soot
from Earth Prime was totally
disintegrated by the Sun there is no
green kryptonite from Earth pod and so
there is no weakness for superboy-prime
and that's why I say things are kind of
crazy when it comes to this or at least
there's no weakness no weakness
initially now of course alexander luthor
making its presence known to lex luthor
really just serves the purpose of
allowing him to topple Lex Luthor I mean
that's that's really all there is to it
but at this point what ends up happening
is we basically have power girl you know
after she's going through her own bit of
a little bit of struggle trying to
figure out what direction she was gonna
go and whose side she was going to
choose what she did is she came to a
middle ground and said what we can do is
we can't just show up on the dorsum of
all the superheroes that exists right
now and say we're going to eradicate you
and replace you with something better
what she says is we have to work out a
compromise there's no reason why these
two universes can't exist at the same
time so again this is Jeff Jones
setting up with the return of the
multiverse but what is up happening here
is when she returns back to the
headquarters of everyone she basically
ends up discovering that all these
different individuals Martian Manhunter
when he was taken black Adam when he was
kidnapped all of them have been attached
to this massive pillar this huge obelisk
that seems to have been constructed out
of the remains
of the anti-monitor now again what Jeff
Jones is doing here is Jeff Jones is
basically saying look the anti-monitor
is still a thing that existed crisis on
Infinite Earths happen the anti-monitor
is a concept it's not something that I'm
basically wiping out in its entirety but
this is about the extent that we get
with the anti-monitor himself in terms
of the anti-monitor actually coming back
as we know him that'll be done as part
of Jeff Jones Sinestro Corps war but
it'll actually come out of the
reformation of the multiverse from
Infinite Crisis but what we end up doing
here is we end up finding out that with
Alexander Luthor and superboy-prime
being the true individuals behind the
destruction or I guess really you know
that all this damage at all these these
evil deeds of course what's basically
happened as they have effectively become
bad guys now what this does is it begs
the question are they really bad guys or
are they good guys the funny thing about
this is that their actions are given to
us by virtue of what we see around them
you know we see them kidnapping heroes
we see them you know hooking them up to
the giant habla so you see them with the
intention of bringing the multiverse
back but wiping out all the different
heroes and so on and so forth but it
also you know it's it's like this like a
hypothetical scenario if I came to you
and I brought you over to the side of a
lake and I said in five minutes this guy
who's fishing right now is gonna be
killed by a man who comes up behind him
and slips as you know slips his throat
five minutes later exactly what I
predicted would happen somebody comes up
behind the fisherman slices his throat
and that's the end of him now on the
surface it's well that guy killed a
fisherman he's an evil man but what if I
told you the reason why he slipped that
fisherman's throat is because that
murderer is trying to feed his family
and he's doing it the only way he knows
how
because he doesn't know how to fish sure
the question could be asked why did he
ask the fishermen to teach him how to
fish but he was thinking in the moment
he was doing what he thought was right
and that's why I say these are kind of
interesting but then it also brings into
play the idea of results it Breezer to
play the idea of motivation sure what
they want to do is the right thing but
how they go about it is important too
and if what they do is basically start
kidnapping all these different
superheroes with the intention of
channeling their power into a single
pillar which in turn will restore the
multiverse then are they really good
guys and so again with power girl
basically learning about all this this
is when Alexander Luthor essentially
says take her out if you're not with us
you're against us and so at this point
power girl is basically an enemy but
what we also end up finding here is
again we basically end up learning that
Lois Lane one of the motivation
behind the earth - Superman is at Lois
Lane is essentially done you know earth
- Lois Lane is basically dying and so
earth to Superman was in a vulnerable
state alexander luthor began to prey on
that and what alexander luthor said you
know what's basically got a whispering
you know evil deeds you know on the
shoulders of Superman and such as saying
hey look man if we can bring back earth
to Lois Lane will live we'll keep her
alive now all this did was feed
Alexander Luthor's purpose of trying to
basically restore the multiverse and
create a perfect earth the issue with
this is that with superboy-prime
standing alongside alexander luthor
civil war crimes motivation is much much
simpler superboy-prime isn't looking for
some grandiose thing he's not looking to
take over all things in existence at
least not right now
Superboy Prime's motivation is that he
hates Conner Kent and the reason why is
because of the fact that Conner Kent
carries the mantle of Superboy
but Conner Kent is not being Superboy
soon y-prime basically looks at
everything that's happened and says we
sacrificed our existence we sacrifice
our lives in order to create a better
world for all these superheroes to live
in and all they're doing is squandering
it all they're doing is refusing to be
superheroes all they're doing it's
fighting among one another all they're
doing is screwing everything up
and so in Superboy's you know so we're
Prime's mind Conner Kent is not Superboy
and if he's not going to act like
Superboy he doesn't deserve to live as
Superboy and so again see what Prime's
whole motivation is just personal I mean
it's it's basic and it's personal but
the cool thing about it is we get to see
him destroy everyone and so again what
is up happening here is that with Lois
Lane earth to Lois Lane continuing to
succumb to her various younger illness
ends up happening is of course Earth -
Superman arrives on the scene Alexander
Luthor says hey look man just chillier
chill here hang out with her everything
will be fine the other half of this is
that with Power Girl having been subdued
the dog is let off his leash
superboy-prime says look let me go find
Conner Ken let me deal with Conner Kent
Alexander Luthor says okay now up until
this point it's been standard comics
explained ladies and gentlemen of the
rob Corps things are about to pop off
all right so the cool thing here god
I've been waiting for this I had to
explain everything in order to make it
make sense I've been waiting for this
more right now superboy-prime rolls up
on Conner Kent's home and the crazy
thing about this is Conner Kent doesn't
know who he is
superboy-prime is you know what color
accounts like who are you super where
prawns responses I'm the super boy the
world needs you know I'm the super boy
the world deserves
you are not super boy now of course the
funny thing the the funniest thing about
this is Conner Kent tries to hold his
own right like hunter Kent's just like
man I'm gonna who this guy is but I'm
gonna take him out Conner Kent starts
punching back so on and so forth
Superboy Prime's responses man you
better come strong 30 racks Conner kid
absolutely crushes him and that's the
craziest thing about this is because
it's just superboy-prime and unbridled
rage it's just the wrath of
superboy-prime that's all this is now of
course with the fact that that Conner
Kent's been damaged in the fact that
he's engaged in this massive conflict
and he's essentially losing he sends out
an SOS to the Titans now the funny thing
about this is like can see Sam's mark
like Wonder Girl
alright cassie sandsmark shows up hey
guys I brought the Titans and the Teen
Titans and the JSA let's jam Superboy
proms like I don't give a damn dude he
superboy-prime wrecks them all that's
the coolest thing about this he's
ripping off arms he's ripping off leg
he's like oh it's the coolest thing that
I've ever seen and that's why I love
this so much it's because it is
superboy-prime losing his mind and
that's why so many people love his
character but the other half of this is
Geoff Johns writes him so well I mean
yeah if superboy-prime Vendrell is
superboy-prime lashing out its
superboy-prime wrecking everyone but
what he's doing the entire time is you
saying you're ruining me you're making
me like you you're making me evil you're
making me bad you're making me a
corrupted person and the crazy thing is
that all these heroes are just fighting
off against them as best they can and it
is absolutely amazing because what it
does is it gives superboy-prime
character it gives him so much
development it's tough it's proud top it
gives superboy-prime
so much development because what he does
is he doesn't see himself for what he is
he doesn't see him suffer what he's
doing he's a guy that's fighting the
entirety of the of the Teen Titans
trying to be mean the entirety of the
Titans fighting the half of the justice
Society of America because in his mind
they don't deserve to be heroes well who
superboy-prime to make that declaration
whose superboy-prime to decide who's a
hero and who's not a hero superboy-prime
is kind of like a reflection of a lot of
comic-book fans who said things need to
go back the way they were because the
way they are now is bad I mean bad
according to you but not bad according
to everyone and so because of that you
know superboy-prime
has a lot of bill here and that's what
makes it so cool is because this entire
fight happens over the span of you know
five or six pages but the way that it's
done is so cool and that's what I think
geoff johns he's an amazing writer just
because of the fact that he's so good at
building characters even if it's only in
a very short amount of time but because
the fact that that Superboy Pratt is
basically this guy that no one seems to
be to be able to take out because of the
fact that Superboy farm is just crushing
person after person after person
knocking them down like dominos what is
up happening here and this is this is
man yeah fanboy one of the coolest
things here is that Jay Garrick Wally
West and Bart Allen race him try to race
him into the Speed Force now this is
crazy because you got to think there are
all kinds of beings that superboy-prime
is fought you know and of course that's
one of the reasons why Geoff Johns
really seemed to choose him was because
of the fact that basically
superboy-prime is Silver Age Superman
it's 1950 Superman the Superman who is
pulling a chain of planets out of the
dying solar system it's the Superman who
sneezed and destroyed a solar system you
know it's that version of Superman
initially superboy-prime had no
weaknesses when he was first introduced
into DC Comics none he wasn't weak to
red Sun to red solar radiation
kryptonite didn't exist he wasn't weak
to magic he had no weaknesses whatsoever
and Geoff Johns plays on this he says
look he's faster than every version of
Superman he's stronger than every
version of Superman you know he's more
capable than all the other superheroes
that he's fighting against he's
literally a one-man army
who's gonna be able to stop him but was
bar down in Wally West and Jay Garrick
trying to race him into the Speed Force
by God it takes everything they have to
try to push him in but this is when Jeff
John sets the stage for the return of
Barry Allen and the reason why is
because try as they might and as
difficult as it may be they can't do it
on their own so what happens
Barry Allen reaches out from the Speed
Force and pulls superboy-prime
in
that's what's so cool is because keep in
mind Barry Allen after the end of crisis
on Infinite Earths hopped up from time
to time I mean DC basically said he's
still around but we didn't know what
they were going to do with him we didn't
know if he was ever gonna come back we
didn't know if he was gonna be gone
forever we had no idea what was gonna
happen the Barry Allen reaching out from
a speed force and yanking him in is
amazing because basically every body has
er everybody's able to pull suit or
Prime in there and that essentially
seems to be the end of him and so what
is up happening here is with Alexander
Luthor having completed this massive
pillar channeling all these energies
back into himself and basically using it
to reform the multiverse what he does is
he basically restores earth to and so
what we get is earth one new earth and
earth two laying the foundation for the
return of the multiverse in DC Comics
okay
so picking up with a second half of
Infinite Crisis I really think that like
this second half is a lot easier to
digest than the first I know what the
first half I threw a lot at you guys
just because Geoff Johns what he writes
his stories usually when it comes like
these big crossover events it's like the
first part is like here's all the stuff
you need to know then the second part is
like and we're on to the action and you
get a good blend
it's just Geoff Johns was using Infinite
Crisis as a way to wrap up a lot of
different things to remove a lot of
different things from the DC landscape
now some of this was like editorial in a
for example when we get to the second
about Dick Grayson but actually find out
that editorial had a different intention
than what we saw in the story itself but
there were a lot of things that ended up
happening behind the scenes that
influenced how this story was done
because DC was looking to Infinite
Crisis to change things up now I think
this makes a really really good talking
point because at the end of the last
video we talked about how the multiverse
had returned and the idea here is that
with crisis on Infinite Earths it was a
line wide reboot I mean it was it was a
hard reboot everything was just reset
from one with Infinite Crisis it's not
that way Jeff John's really just kind of
comes along and says well you get to
stay and you get to stay you got to go
but you get to stay and you get to stay
it's really just kind of going through
and basically it is revitalizing
characters and returning them to their
roots and this is never more so evident
than when we pick up with the return of
the multiverse and the restoration of
earth - now remember earth 2 is
basically the universe where all the
Golden Age heroes existed so basically
all the superheroes if you do Google
searches or you look them up or anything
superheroes that were first created in
the 1930s and 1940s and the really
really early part like the first five
years of the 1950's that was all Golden
Age stuff when the multiverse is
recreated by Alexander Luthor suddenly
people like Jay Garrick just began
vanishing all over the place and no one
knows where they are of course earth to
Superman earth to Lois Lane they vanish
as well what we find out is that they've
been sent to earth - and so really
what's happening here is Geoff Johns is
basically saying after crisis on
Infinite Earths a lot of the characters
who were introduced before crisis on
Infinite Earths in the multiverse on a
different earth they were just kind of
rolled over into the main DC continuity
in the new earth continuity after crisis
on Infinite Earths but because the
multiverse is back basically all these
different heroes are going to the earths
where they first appeared at so for
example we have members of the Shazam
family that show up on earth s and the
reason why is because before crisis on
Infinite Earths the Shazam family
existed on earth s and so that's
basically what's happening here it's
just returning all these different
characters back to where it was that
they came from now a brawl like a huge
majority a bulk of these characters uh
you know characters like that like Matt
Smith that's man I know I said that's
man in the other video characters like
bats man he stays simply because of the
fact that he's just a character that's
so popular the deserts to counterparts
not gonna be found I mean you're only
gonna see him on earth one he's one of
these weird exceptions switching back
over to Batman himself the idea is that
with whether I having had all these
different Oh matches and you know kind
of running amuck and so on Batman's main
focus is to basically take out these
there you know take out brother I
eliminate brother i from the equation
and then the Omax will fall respectively
because remember the Omax only exists
because of the connection between
brother I and the Omax assume his
brother eyes destroyed these you know
nano these these nanobots whatever it is
that surround these normal humans or
basically deactivate and these humans
will go back to the way they were before
now in truth this was just DC giving
themselves an out right it was just a
way of saying hey look brother is gonna
be defeated and it's not gonna cost the
lives of some you know two million
people in order to do it they're all
just gonna go back to the way they were
before but the other half of this is we
actually have Booster Gold
bringing to Batman Jaime Reyes now I
call him Jaime Reyes some people like
Joel call him Jaime Reyes I think it
really just kind of depends I'm used to
pronouncing it Jaime resume that's
that's I don't know why it would be
pronounced a different way but Jaime
Reyes is basically the new Blue Beetle
keep in mind and
countdown to Infinite Crisis we talked
about how Ted Kord the blue beetle at
the time was killed by Maxwell Lord but
the funny thing about this is that when
it came to the blue beetle landscape
with the exception of Ted Kord everybody
has powers because of a scarab that they
possess now originally in DC Comics the
Blue Beetle was a man named Dan Garrett
Danny Garrett's history is a little
fuzzy if you go to like Fox feature
syndicate or you were to look up Fox
feature syndicate what you would find
out is that Blue Beetle at that point in
time was more akin to like a detective
or something along the lines of like you
know Green Hornet you know somebody
similar to that as opposed to the Blue
Beetle that you most commonly think of
but the idea here is that when Blue
Beetle Dan Garrett was effectively taken
over by DC as a whole his entire history
and origin was revamped to a degree to
where it was similar but he actually had
powers that were derived from a scarab
and the Scarab effectively went away
when Ted Kord became the New Beetle and
the reason why is because of the fact
that DC was looking for a more grounded
character so the doubleu Beetle scarab
solely just existed as like a trophy in
the room are really in the the base of
operations for Ted Kord and Ted Kord
himself had no actual powers he was just
a super smart guy but what ended up
happening is because of the fact that
Infinite Crisis was designed to fulfill
Jeff's John's desire to take a lot of
comics for as many as he could in terms
of characters and send them back to
their roots when we eventually saw Ted
Kord stumbled across the wizard Shazam
and his efforts to figure out you know
what was going on with Maxwell Lord Ted
Kord was killed the Blue Beetle scarab
was left on Shazam when the rock of
eternity was destroyed by the specter
that Beetle scarab landed on earth and
then took possession of Jaime Reyes and
so what that meant is that Jaime Reyes
went forward as the new Blue Beetle with
powers now the caveat to all this is
that within this story Infinite Crisis
and even going into like 50 tubes and
going into a lot of stories of focus on
his character the issue is that Jaime
Reyes does not have any control of the
Blue Beetle scarab it operates with a
will of its own is more instinctive or
reactive than anything else and so
because of this this is basically
introducing his character into DC and
showing us or at least giving us an idea
of what to expect now of course Booster
Gold bringing in Jaime Reyes - uh -
Batman is done because of the fact that
no Ric Bucher goal is a time traveler
and in his future he already knows about
the events that are going on right now
and what he tells Batman is you're going
to try to find brother
you're not going to be able to find it
but the Blue Beetle scarab can help you
locate it because of the fact that it
can allow its user to almost do anything
they need to at any particular point in
time it's almost like the last wide
event with you know star brand for those
of you guys who were familiar with Jeff
R but not with Jeff Jeff with Jonathan
Hickman Avengers and New Avengers but
the fact remains here that basically
Booster Gold says is Blue Beetle will
help you find brother I because you will
not be able to locate it on your own so
at this point what we do is we switch
back over to earth to now with regards
to earth hue we focused largely on
Superman and the idea was remember he
was told by Alex Lane Alexander Luthor
if we restore the multiverse then Lois
Lane and you you guys can go back to
earth too and Lois Lane will live so
because of the fact that she was dying
for reasons that we couldn't necessarily
like really weren't really explained it
was just kind of like the idea of old
age or something along those lines but
despite being on earth to Lois Lane dies
anyway now this is one of the most
touching moments of the story and the
reason why is because of the fact that
it is an absolute law of the universe
that Superman always rescues Lois Lane
Superman could be in a village of
children who are being bombarded by
conventional warfare and he will leave
to save Lois Lane but the idea here is
this is Golden Age Superman
this is 1930s 1940s incorruptible
Superman back in those days he always
saved Lois Lane that was the crux of the
story will Superman get to Lois Lane and
ton find out in the next issue that was
the way those stories were written back
then and so with Lois Lane dying this is
an experience that earth-2 Saran has
never felt before there's never been an
instance where he's ever had to even
question whether or not Lois Lane was
going to survive he was always there but
with her death with the scream that he
lets out the fact that he's feeling this
much suffering in this much pain it
breaks the barrier between earth one and
earth two and Superman on earth one
hears it and that's how much suffering
goes into the show that's how much
suffering goes into the screen now again
this is geoff johns kind of tying up all
these loose ends and having it you know
really going forward the intention of
returning superheros back to the way
they're supposed to be now we'll find
out with Final Crisis a lot of that ends
up getting changed by Grant Morrison but
happening here as we transitioned over
to Wonder Woman and Wonder Woman of
Earth one is actually visited by Wonder
Woman of Earth to the Golden Age Wonder
Woman and the cool thing about this is
that the Golden Age Wonder Woman takes
earth one wonder woman you know Diana on
this journey where she basically
explains look you're not a hero right
now you're not acting like a hero you
don't need to prove yourself to anybody
like you've been a leader you've been a
queen you know you have been an
ambassador you've done virtually
everything the only thing you need to be
right now is human and that's the
coolest thing about this because what
Geoff Johns is basically saying is that
in a lot of ways the modern superheroes
at the time this story was written 2005
2006 the superheroes had lost their
humanity
they weren't superheroes anymore it was
almost like you could write this story
as a precursor to injustice gods among
us right like they lose their humanity
they lose what it is that makes them
heroes and because of this they
basically fight amongst each other I
mean the injustice university or they
fight amongst each other so on and so
forth in this story it's a lot of the
same way they've lost their humanity and
insight of losing their humanity they
fail to take into account that the
actions that they engage in especially
Wonder Woman when she killed Maxwell
Lord have an impact that resonates
beyond herself humanity won't say well
oh my god
wonder will he kill Maxwell Lord Wonder
Woman is a terrible person none of them
what humanity will say is Wonder Woman
killed Maxwell Lord Wonder Woman's part
of the Justice League
superheroes are dangerous that's exactly
the way the events played out and that's
the case that earth to Wonder Woman is
making be a hero be human understand
everyone makes mistakes you've made
mistakes
Batman makes mistakes Superman makes
mistakes learn from them and become a
better person and so because of this we
transition back over to Superman on
earth too and we end up having this
really cool battle between himself and
Superman on earth one and that's kind of
the funny thing here because it's almost
like experience versus experience which
one comes and comes out right here but
the funny thing about this is that it's
actually Superman from Earth one that
talks reason into Golden Age Superman
and the reason why I say that is because
of the fact that Golden Age Superman is
fighting out of anger he's fighting out
of Wrath he's fighting out of rage and
the reason why is he says Lois Lane
didn't die because it was unavoidable
Lois Lane died because she was exposed
to the corruption that is what makes you
superheroes who you are she was exposed
to the corruption of your evil deeds she
was exposed to the corruption of your
more
ambiguity your willingness to do things
that that would basically make you a
villain as opposed to being a hero now
the funny thing about this is Wonder
Woman steps in 101 basically says look
you know you guys have to stop and this
is one's bold name Superman really lets
them have it he says you're not heroes
not in any sense of the word your
anti-heroes your questionable heroes
sometimes you do good things but it
doesn't a tell them for the bad things
you do and that's really what that's the
funny thing about this is a case could
be made for that now somebody in the
comment section of the video about on
that project you made a really good
point where they're basically saying
look if all the old stories were nothing
but heroes doing the right thing all the
time that would get boring hence the
reason why we started getting stories
like The Dark Knight Returns and stuff
like that where we sort of seen the
darker side of Heroes but what geoff
johns is saying is that is something
that needs to be there there needs to be
a time when the the morality of
superheroes is questioned when the
morality of superheroes is ambiguous
that's something that needs to exist the
problem is when it becomes the status
quo that's the issue
superhero should always be someone to
look up to they should always be
something to aspire to the humanity of
heroes is what bridges the gap between
them as you know comic book characters
and us as the reader and it's what helps
us identify with them but what we don't
want to read her stories where all we
see is darkened draggy what we don't
want to see our stories where either it
reflects the real world or it makes the
real world look worse than it is and so
because of that Superman says you've
lost your way now the best
counter-argument to this is Superman
from Earth one when Golden Age
Superman's ranting on he's talking about
how he comes from a world where
everything's perfect Superman from Earth
one says well that can't be possible
because a perfect world wouldn't need a
Superman and so that's the beauty of all
this is because this is when Golden Age
Superman begins to put two and two
together when he begins talking about
you know how Alexander Luthor is trying
to find that one perfect earth this is
when building a Superman realizes
Alexander Luthor is working against them
and so what we end up finding out is
that with this giant Tower that's been
built you know with you know I guess a
resemblance to the anti-monitor that
alexander luthor kind of switches over
and basically says that for reasons that
he can't begin to comprehend for reasons
he doesn't understand the multiverse
begins and ends with Superman now there
is an actual reason for this but it's
not tied directly into the comics it's
not like the multiverse was born
directly from Superman in DC Comics he's
not the origin of the multiverse the
reason behind there
actually goes all the way back to the
1950s so going on a bit of a journey
here kind of time traveling a bit back
in the nineteen 1930s 1940s when
Superman first showed up and comics um
he could just jump really high run
really fast and bullets could bounce off
of them but it's time progressed and
especially you know being influenced by
his radio show or kryptonite was
introduced for the first time and with
the you know the the Fleischer Studios
when they basically introduced the
ability for him to fly those were rolled
over into the comics but no explanation
was given it was just one day he could
jump really hide the next day he could
fly and we didn't know why and so what
DC did is they came back in 1956 with
Barry Allen and they said well you know
if that was a different universe that
was earth to earth one is the universe
it has the flash Barry Allen now because
of this what uh
what Geoff Johns is doing is using
Alexander Luthor as a meta commentary by
basically saying that it does all begin
and end with Superman the questions of
you know the questions that led to DC
introduced in the multiverse all stemmed
from the radical change in Superman's
powers that were never explained and so
again it's really just one of those
funny kind of meta-commentary things but
for those of you guys who are impatient
those of you guys who were tired of
waiting those of you guys who are like I
want to see superboy-prime
this is when we get them so the funny
thing about this is that because a
majority or at least a lot of the
different heroes innovation existed on
earth that were originally created and
you know the the Golden Age and have
their own universes because they've been
switched back over to those universes
the ranks of the Titans and the Teen
Titans have been absolutely decimated I
mean half their numbers are gone and
they don't even know where those guys
have gone to and so because of this it
really comes down to Conner Kent and to
Dick Grayson Nightwing to try to fend
off destroy this tower and basically
converge all the different earths back
into back into New Earth and so what we
do is we switch over to Tokyo and we
actually pick up with Bart Allen now the
funny thing about this is that it's not
initially explained here instead we just
have Bart Allen emerging from the Speed
Force as an adult wearing the flash
costume and he begins just kind of
rambling on and going on about nonsense
talking about how we couldn't hold him
we couldn't keep him contained the
question is asked well who are you
talking about and he says it's him
it's superboy-prime so superboy-prime
has re-emerged from the speedforce gotta
love this story it's managed a subdued
I love cat hello Infinite Crisis man I
love this story so much so the funny
thing is switching back over to Batman
Booster Gold and and and Blue Beetle
again this is just kind of a reefa
miliary it's reminding us of the power
of this new Blue Beetle in the sense
that he can basically vibrate through
dimensional barriers we can you can also
reveal things that are hidden between
dimensional barriers now what this does
is it basically deactivates the cooking
device of brother I and it allows Batman
and everybody else to basically stow
aboard and begin the process of trying
to shut brother I data so we just get
all these little sequences these small
little subplots converging into one
another to lead to the conclusion of
this story really the last flight with
superboy-prime within Infinite Crisis
anyway but the funny thing is also
switching over to Stonehenge it's
grabbing what's left of all the
superheroes on earth and the spectre
suddenly appears and ends up destroying
Deborah car mio Darnell now the reason
why I Debra chromeo de Deborah Deborah
the reason why I did word was destroyed
Deborah oh my god
Star Sapphire Deborah the reason why she
was destroyed it is because of the fact
that she is currently Star Sapphire
around the time of Infinite Crisis but
Geoff Johns is going to go forward in
the Green Lantern mythos and rework the
entirety of the Star Sapphire mythos and
so he's basically like cheese in the way
she's not going to be part of the story
that I'm making we're just gonna get rid
of her and that's it she's gone no muss
no fuss nobody really even asked any
questions it's just like and she's gone
now and that's it so it was just one of
those funny little moments this sort of
gets wrapped in there but what we end up
doing here is to basically switch over
to Alexander Luthor continuing to
experiment with the multiverse itself
this idea that the Superman and Lex
Luthor will are destined to always be at
odds with one another that's one of the
reasons why a lot of people who are
reading DC rebirth right now believe
that Lex Luthor in the new 52 is gonna
go back to being a bad guy simply
because of the fact that they read
stories like Infinite Crisis they see
these lines that geoff johns threw out
the guy who wrote Infinite Crisis and is
now the one controlling DC rebirth and
they see things where Alexander Luthor
says Superman and Lex Luthor are always
destined to fight one another so again
it's all these really cool moments what
we end up finding out is that with with
cassie sandsmark Wonder Girl basically
joining alongside Dick Grayson and
encounter Kent Superboy to free all
these different superheroes who have
been attached to the tower that Martian
Manhunter a Power Girl they all begin to
join the fray and it's this mad dash to
face off against Alexander Luthor
destroy the tower
try to save the multiverse now the
reason why this whole act is being
committed why everything needs to be
saved is because what Jeff John's dead
is he basically established a time clock
what he said is that with regards to the
creation of the multiverse it's not a
contained thing you can't just like
bring one earth back and then bring
another earth back and then two or three
more introspect then what you do is you
start a chain reaction to become a prime
mover you initiate the creation of the
multiverse and then suddenly earths
start popping up left and right they
just start activating all over the place
and is basically an endless cycle that
will lead to Infinite Earths the problem
with this is that it's not created
organically it's created artificially
and so what that means is it basically
invokes a half-life each earth only has
half the energy of the earth that came
before so it's diminishing returns and
what will happen is it'll lead to earths
that are basically completely and
totally unstable and when those earths
begin to destroy it will create a
cascading event that will basically wipe
out the multiverse and so because of
that the entire multiverse is in and of
itself completely unstable and so
eventually it'll all just collapse in on
itself and so in order to keep the end
of all things from happening the tower
has to be destroyed now what this also
does is a sea superboy-prime showing up
and just absolutely wrecking black atom
now one of the questions that I've seen
asked on Twitter different things like
that when I did the video on the origin
of superboy-prime is does magic affect
superboy-prime the answer to that
question is no superboy-prime is not
affected by magic geoff johns confirms
it in this story now the other half of
this is because of the fact that
superboy-prime was basically you know
like the strong arm of alexander luthor
because he had killed members of the
titans because he was such a villainous
guy what we end up having is all these
different superheroes focusing their
efforts on him first and then tending to
Alexander Luthor later now switching
back over to Batman again the cool thing
about this is it again we kind of get
this back and forth between Batman and
Batman and and brother eye as well as
all these different superheroes facing
off against superboy-prime
but what we end up finding out is that
Batman's idea he basically says look I
designed you physically I may not
control your software but I designed you
physically I can activate and deactivate
aspects of you and what we end up
finding out is the whole thing here is
basically just a ruse he's buying time
in order to allow mr. terrific the third
smartest man in the world to begin the
process of activating the propulsion
system for brother I and
moving him out from work he's currently
located out now the reason why this
matters is because of the fact that if
brother eye is destabilized it'll go
towards the efforts of destroying the
Tower of Alexander Lutheran so again
this is really just a scenario where
brother I begins recalling all these
different Omax directly to where
Batman's located and Batman in turn
invokes the Green Lantern's so that's
how the Green Lantern's begin getting
involved in this now they were already
involved to a degree but they're more so
now than they were before because we
basically have two major skirmishes
taking place right now we have the
battle where the tower is which is where
superboy-prime Power Girl Martian
Manhunter so on and then we have this
battle out in space that brother I which
is Batman Booster Gold Blue Beetle and
then like a ton of like a whole bunch of
members of the Green Lantern's now this
is cool because we basically get round
two of superboy-prime facing off against
Superboy but the funny thing is here
much like the first time around while
Superboy is able to hold off while you
know Connor Kent's able to fight pretty
well at the end of the day it doesn't
matter you know superboy-prime
is still able to overpower him now in a
last-ditch effort you know some kind of
a trump card hunter can't fly
superboy-prime into the tower and
destroys it and what it does is it
basically shatters the multiverse and
then takes all these different earths
and restores them back into new earth
and so it was almost like this this
whole you know explosion of Earth's
outward and then those Earth's coming
back into new earth so that's one of the
things if you ever do like Google
searches you ever do any research and
they talk about how during Infinite
Crisis the multiverse was reborn and
then destroyed that's exactly what this
means the problem is that in the midst
of its fight with superboy-prime Conner
Kent is killed by superboy-prime and so
again this is kind of a crazy scenario
now one of the funny things about this
is that Conner Kent was supposed to stay
dead the reason why he was supposed to
be gone is because of the fact that
remember Infinite Crisis serves as a
soft reboot and this is one of those
instances we were talking about or Jeff
Jones with society who gets to leave and
who gets to stay you know who gets to
live and who gets to die Conner Kent was
supposed to die because he was just a
holdover from the death and return of
Superman and DC just never really knew
what to do with him and in fact if you
go and read Jeff Jones you know his
whole run on like Teen Titans what he's
basically doing is building up to this
point where he would work Conner Kent
was supposed to die the problem with
this is that DC editorial didn't want to
keep it that way and in fact he actually
comes back during like it was like the
Legion of three worlds or some like that
I can't remember off the top my head
where the story was called
but he's basically resurrected what is a
gets thrown into a Kryptonian rear you
know regeneration matrix and they end up
bringing him back the same way they
brought back the old Superman the other
half of this is that with the death of
Conner Kent this is when they basically
say superboy-prime is beyond the point
of no return now the other half of this
equation is remember we still have the
secret 6 the super Society of secret
villains alexander luthor posing as Lex
Luthor freed all these different
villains from across the world and
they're all basically tearing cities
apart ripping things to pieces just
having a good old time and so because of
this earth to Superman an earth 1
Superman of course basically take out
doomsday and then from there their
question is who do we take out next and
their immediate focus is superboy-prime
but the funny thing about this is that
Superboy prom actually faces off against
Bart Allen and this is when Geoff Johns
begins to harken at one of the only two
weaknesses that superboy-prime has the
first weakness is a legitimate weakness
which will actually see later on here in
this story but the second is really more
of like a fear or phobia superboy-prime
is terrified of speedsters and the
reason why is because of the fact that
when Superboy prom was forced back into
the Speed Force to his mind he was stuck
there for years now in terms of the
armor that he wears this is something
that Geoff Johns does not fully explain
he addresses it but he doesn't really
fully explain it all we know is that
superboy-prime built this armor to
basically absorb solar radiation into
his body and to store it uh while he was
in the Speed Force now the reason why
this matters is because for Superman for
your average run-of-the-mill regular
Superman Superman as a whole just
absorbs solar radiation he's a solar
battery all right his body absorbs solar
radiation to the point that it just
can't absorb anymore so that if he ends
up going to a planet where there's like
a red Sun or something like that
his body will basically use up that
solar radiation until there's none left
and then he'll just be a regular person
the suit that superboy-prime has takes
it a step further it's like a battery
pack for solar radiation he puts the
suit on and then the suit itself absorbs
solar radiation in addition to what his
body already has and so it allows them
to fight longer harder and faster than
any of the other Superman or superheroes
now and true that doesn't really matter
anyway because he's already so
overpowered that it almost makes the
point moot but what it does is it pushes
his powers a step further now with
regards to the fact that he is running
an absolute muck here what is up
happening is he basically leaves the
superheroes on a merry chase and isn't
being encountered by the Green Lantern's
but before we get into that what
when I do is I want to switch back over
to Alexander Luthor and the fight with
the various superheroes are subdue these
members of the secret six
what is up happening here is that
Alexander Luthor goes to kill Batman and
Dick Grayson jumps in the way now if you
they'll read interviews DC will tell you
Dick Grayson was supposed to die he was
not supposed to live he was supposed to
be gone and the reason why was because
of the fact that DC was looking at Dick
Grayson as a whole and they said this
guy's been around since like 1940 since
Detective Comics number 39 or something
I tell number what issue it was on top
my head but he's been around for decades
I mean he's been around for years and
years and years and years and they were
like it's time to get rid of him and
replace him with someone new the problem
with this and the reason why DC was
talked about talked out of it was
because there were other members and the
DC camp that were like if you killed
Dick Grayson fans will riot like they
will lose it you cannot kill Dick
Grayson that's one of the biggest
mistakes you would have made they would
have lost their minds so in the end DC
chose not to kill Dick Grayson and just
have him have them injured really really
really bad but because the fact that
superboy-prime basically takes off to
the depths of space
what is up happening here is that how
Jordan calls in all the other Green
Lantern's that are out in their various
sectors recalls them all to the location
of where superboy-prime is heading to
and has them all face off and so what we
end up having is superboy-prime versus a
guy gardener led Green Lantern team and
let me tell you some Rosslyn is a sight
to behold ooh this is one of the coolest
things ever because they're making
statements you know like the thin green
line will stop him called sewai Proms
responds like you guys don't know cold
and he starts killing just ripping him
to pieces I mean there's there's no
contest here I mean he's just tearing
him to shreds he crushes them so bad
that the standard operating procedure of
the Green Lantern's to preserve life is
cast aside and they're given permission
to kill superboy-prime now the reason
why this is important is because if a
green lantern unless his permission is
given if a green lantern goes and tries
to kill someone
the ring will stop them the ring will
keep them from doing that that's one of
the things that Geoff Johns really focus
on a lot when it came to the lead-up to
Sinestro Corps war and during the
Sinestro Corps war is that the Guardians
of the Universe permanently installed in
the Green Lantern rings the ability to
kill members of the Sinestro Corps
because what Sinestro did is when he
made his own Lantern Corps he basically
set it up so that his range
we'll allow members of the Sinestro
Corps to kill anybody and so it was
basically you know creating a way to
counter the Green Lantern's so because
of this the Green Lantern's are given
the ability to kill and it doesn't
matter superboy-prime
is still crushing and stomping every
last one of them let me tell you
something man let me tell you something
if God was writing superboy-prime line
now is what it would look like right now
is one of the coolest things that I've
ever seen to see him just crushing all
these Green Lantern's now the reason why
this is important is because when we
pick up with Green Lantern Corps
recharge
they'll reference this moment they'll
actually talk about how he killed some
40 Green Lantern's without even trying
and so what is up happening is that in
this last-ditch effort with his
recognition that super war crime simply
does not seem to be able to be stopped
earth once Superman and her 2suit man
grab him and race him to the red Sun
from where Krypton was destroyed now the
funny thing about this is this is
basically Jeff John showing the
arrogance and how far superboy-prime is
falling because in his mind to his
immediate thought well you know they're
taking me to kryptonite you know to it
to where Krypton used to be where that
kryptonite doesn't affect me like these
guys are boneheads they're not paying
attention flying him through a red Sun
effectively begins to negate all their
powers it destroys the armor of
superboy-prime and then it begins to
basically draw away the energies of
Superman because remember they start to
lose their powers in the presence of a
red Sun and so like asteroids falling on
to a planet they crash onto the Green
Lantern planet Mogo and then they do
they all just start duking it out now in
the process of all this a superboy-prime
kills Golden Age Superman you know or
really kind of beats him to death but
the cool thing about this is that earth
one Superman lets superboy-prime have it
and the reason why is because they're
both in the presence of a red Sun now
the reason why I say this is significant
is because remember in our origin story
of superboy-prime red Sun energy did not
affect him he had no weaknesses he
wasn't weak to magic he wasn't weak to
kryptonite or a kryptonite didn't exist
he wasn't weak to red Sun radiation he
was stronger faster you know had more
energy than every suit man who had ever
existed superboy-prime
was in essence 1950s 1960s
Silver Age Superman all strength no
weakness in order for Jeff Jones to be
able to just end this story he had to
give him a weakness and so he basically
just throw his red Sun radiation in
there now in truth Jeff Jones is
probably looking at the obscurity of
Superboy's origin in the sense that is a
very difficult story to find
unless you know where to look you'll
never find it and so it's just
superboy-prime is just this version of
Superman that exists out there that's
really Opie and so I imagine Jeff jobs
just kind of relying on that that
obscurity in order to help him pass the
switch it works I mean it's it's fine I
mean Superboy promise watch as I love
him he's got to have a weakness you know
it just makes sense that we would see
him being weak to red Sun radiation and
so because of this because he's in a
weakened state and his powers are
effectively dwindling away the Green
Lantern's arrived just in time to
basically encase him and Green Lantern
energy and then whisk him off to a
science cell on OA in the center of the
universe where he's basically gonna be
held prisoner in the presence of a red
Sun which again completely negates his
powers and so what is up happening here
is that with Golden Age Superman dying
it really just kind of transitions to
the fallout of all these different
events and it's basically just sort of
this epilogue where it continues on with
things as they're heading forward you
know the idea that we still have the new
Blue Beetle Jaime Reyes you know where
these characters are gonna go from power
girl Wonder Girl cassie sandsmark the
new spectre all these different things
that are sort of coming out of Infinite
Crisis going forward into the future of
DC Comics but for those things they're
not really relevant to us because we're
doing this strictly to help us
understand what's going on in Geoff
Johns Green Lantern mythos a little bit
better but there's actually two
epilogues that come into this story the
first is that we pick up with alexander
luthor who survived everything he
survived the whole return of the
multiverse all that kind of good stuff
but his idea is I'm going to try again
like one day I will try again I'm going
to recreate the multiverse and I'm going
to find the perfect earth but what is up
happening is that as he's making his way
through Gotham he's attacked and killed
by the Joker and the reason why is
because the real Lex Luthor shows up and
says the biggest mistake you made
besides impersonating me and all that
kind of stuff what is that when you
reformed the secret six you didn't
invite the Joker and that's why the
Joker killed him because he didn't get
an invite to the party that encapsulates
Joker so well Joker's the kind of guy to
find out that somebody's having a party
somebody's having like a great big
amazing birthday party in Gotham City
and there's gonna be all kinds of crazy
look like an adult birthday party but
there's gonna be all kinds of crazy
stuff he didn't get an invite so he goes
in there and just shoots the place up
that's the kind of thing that Joker
would do but the other epilogue that we
get is Superboy with all these different
superheroes basically learning
their mistakes really their lessons from
the return of east of an earth to
Superman ones up happening is that with
superboy-prime confined inside of this
science cell he cars the Superboy symbol
onto his chest and then simply says I've
been in places like this before I've
been in worse and I've always managed to
get my way out and so what this does is
this segues directly and a Green Lantern
recharge as part of the Geoff Johns
Green Lantern mythos okay the events of
Dark Knight metal basically confirmed
Final Crisis and tell us the Final
Crisis is in the existence of DC's
continuity as it stands right now the
reason why I make that declaration and
make that statement is because the new
52 erased a lot of things from before
2011 a lot of things that happen in DC
Comics before 2011 were eliminated in
their entirety but in order to make Dark
Knights metal make more sense we're
gonna cover Final Crisis now here's the
deal
Final Crisis is crazy it is it is it is
absolutely bonkers because this is one
of those stories worse just like Grant
Morrison just being crazy that's really
what it is it's Grant Morrison just
being insane those of you guys who don't
know writer Grant Morrison has this
tendency to take these metaphysical
concepts these things like how we
perceive good and evil and then apply
characters to them and say this is the
world this is how it works kind of a
weird scenario but fortunately for us
these are not that extreme when it comes
to like the Final Crisis story they're
just weird his really all it is now what
this initially does is it picks up with
a guy by the name of Dan turbine and Dan
turbine has been around in DC Comics for
quite some time I want to say he
appeared in Detective Comics number 64
in 1941 maybe was 1942 and I believe he
was adjusted like he was actually given
form given a character in the new gods
solo series by Jack Kirby um and we'll
talk more about the new gods here here
in like five seconds but the whole basis
behind this this new gods thing is that
this initially deals with the arrival of
a guy named Orion now Orion just kind of
crashed lands on earth but this is the
first indication that a massive set of
events are happening and the reason for
this is because damn turbine is just a
detective he's just a guy who just goes
and looks at cases different things like
that but when it comes to DC Comics the
new gods were kind of a weird situation
when Jack Kirby originally launched the
whole new guy
fourth-world epic back in the 1970s when
he left Marvel Comics the idea was to
create this wholly separate imprint away
from DC superhero landscape and it would
just be out there by itself in the
middle of no man's land so you would
basically have DC superheroes Batman
Superman Wonder Woman so on and so forth
and then isolated from that and never
crossing over you would have the Fourth
World epic which is where you would get
Darkseid and things along those lines
the problem with this was that Jack
Kirby left before he completed the
project the rumor is that DC treated him
like crap so he ended up leaving and
going back to Marvel again and because
of this he never finished the fourth
world epic and so what DC did is they
grabbed all these concepts of the new
gods and then rolled them over into
their main DC continuity but in the
realm of the pre-crisis on Infinite
Earths landscape because of the fact of
the fourth world were supposed to be
removed from the DC continuity while it
was rolled in it was basically
established as a separate universe
because in 1961 DC made the multiverse
with flash of two worlds and so because
of this with crisis on Infinite Earths
coming along and saying okay there is no
multiverse anymore there's only one
universe DC had to find a way to work
the new gods in as a group that was
originally part of a different universe
but it's now part of the main universe
with all the other superheroes and so
what they did is they went through and I
believe it was in the cosmic Odyssey
series by jim Starlin they went through
and they basically came back and said
okay you have apocalypse and you have
New Genesis apocalypse is where dark
cloud hangs out at New Genesis is where
his mortal enemy highfather hangs out at
and it was all part of the universe they
were just out there and some galaxies
somewhere but eventually events took
place in such a form that things like
the anti-life entity the anti-life
equation and stuff like that sort of
popping up and it basically just walled
off their galaxies and so in effect they
were isolated in an alternate universe
insofar as their galaxy wasn't able to
access anything else and DC use this is
kind of a bootstrap way to say this is
how it is they're coming in to the
superhero universe but it's the reason
why superheroes can't really go to them
but the fact that Orion has basically
died or at least is believed to have
died here's a pretty big deal because
new gods are beings with incredible
amounts of power and for a new god to
basically just be eliminated in their
entirety is something that immediately
just accord with anybody it would be
like if Superman just crashed on a dock
somewhere and then was dead nobody would
know why people would be like what in
the heck happen what in the world took
place here and so the result is that
it's this huge investigation now
remember because the fact that the new
gods are massive in scale one of the big
things that DC did is they came back and
they launched a story called
Infinite Crisis now when it comes to the
different crises DC's done over the
course of their landscape they're pretty
straightforward DC made the multiverse
in 1961 with flash of two worlds they
got rid of the multiverse with crisis on
Infinite Earths in 1955 they brought the
multiverse back in 2006 with Infinite
Crisis and this story Final Crisis makes
the superheroes aware of it but as it
stands right now post Infinite Crisis
the new gods do have their own reality
they have their own universe that kind
of a thing but the idea is that again
with one of them being killed this is
huge news and it actually draws the
attention of everyone because
everybody's aware of who the new gods
are specifically it draws the attention
of the Green Lantern's Jon Stewart Hal
Jordan so and so forth but it also draws
the attention of someone named Renee
Montoya now Renee Montoya was originally
a character who was introduced in Batman
the Animated Series and she was rolled
over in Detective Comics 475 in 1992 but
the idea here is that Renee Montoya is
like Harley Quinn Harley Quinn basically
showed up in Batman the Animated Series
and because this show was so popular DC
and Warner Brothers began grabbing
characters that didn't exist in comics
and then started rolling them over into
the comics now Renee Montoya was just a
detective I mean she of course she was
gay and she had a girlfriend different
things like that but her girlfriend was
killed and what this did is it coincided
with her basically taking over the
mantle of the question I'm throwing a
ton of stuff at you guys
I'm throwing a lot of history of you
guys because there's so much that goes
into this so the question was a guy
named Victor sage and he was basically
created for Charlton comics Charlton
comics sucks they were just one of those
cover book publishers that exists out
there they went belly-up in 1967 and so
the question was rolled over into DC's
landscape the question Victor saved he
was like War Shaq from The Watchmen
right like he was just a guy who showed
up he wore this mask that hid his face
and he just beat the crap out of
criminals at night that's really what he
was he was almost like Batman in a lot
of those ways the idea was that Victor
sage ended up dying and his student at
the time for the most part Renee Montoya
took over the mantle
and this is because of the fact that
Renee Montoya girlfriend had died and
she had become an alcoholic but it was a
way for DC to take a character who was
originally popular in Batman the
Animated Series but it long since lost
her popularity and basically reworked
her in a way that fans would actually
care about her so she doesn't play a
significant role but I figured I'd drop
that little tidbit of knowledge here for
you guys I mean she basically tells Dan
Kerman hey the questions that you're
asking for with all these kids who were
vanishing isn't a place called the
Darkseid Club now of course this also
coincides with you know how Jordan
talking with John Stewart about the idea
that Orion has been killed the problem
with this was that when Jon Stewart
originally tried to get a hold of Hal
Jordan after the eve you know ten eleven
came in basically the warning to the
Green Lantern's that a God had been
killed and somebody needed to
investigate Jon Stewart was not able to
get ahold of Hal Jordan and that's a
very important thing but what we end up
doing is jumping to a group called the
secret society of super villains and
that's exactly what it sounds like it's
just super villains all hanging out
scheming trying to find ways to defeat
heroes different things like that but
one of these characters crops up as a
guy named Libra now libras had virtually
no important aspects in DC Comics at all
this guy did I think he appeared in like
some Justice League story like 111
through 114 or something like that and
that was it the fact that Libra is here
is interesting because we initially
don't know why all we know is that Libra
basically makes the case hey I am going
to give you guys your heart's desires
I'm going to basically give you guys
everything you want to prove that you
guys should hand over control of the
secret society of super villains to me
and then in turn I can lead us down the
path of destroying all the heroes who
were out there now in truth the secret
society is really just kind of like
whatever and there's no reason for them
to believe this because forgot likely
were to suddenly pop up out of nowhere
who's basically had no meaningful
escapades whatsoever and say I'm the
answer to all your problems is nonsense
it's like if you're walking down the
road one day and some guy walks up to
you and says hey I can make all your
wildest dreams come true if you're a
fool you'll follow him but if you have
any measure of common sense you'll be
like get out of here that's ridiculous
but in order to prove that he can
actually do what it is if he says he can
do he ends up killing Martian Manhunter
now this is where the death of Martian
Manhunter comes from for those of you
guys who were following our Green
Lantern videos on
sundays and we picked it with blackest
night were grit we're martian manhunter
comes back as a black lantern he
basically comes back from the dead but
in this instance there was a prison that
was created for supervillains and the
idea was that martian manhunter had
basically infiltrated the prison to
really just kind of keep an eye on
things and report back to the Justice
League but Libra had known about this of
course this was also because of the fact
that Catwoman had figured things out and
basically told Lieber what was going on
but in response when Martian Manhunter
was attacked by the prisoners inside the
prison itself and then quote-unquote
whisked away by Libra he's effectively
killed because remember at this point in
time Martian Manhunter has a literal
weakness to fire and so the results of
this is that Martian Manhunter is dead
and it proves to the various members of
the secret society of super villains
that they can actually pull this off now
what this does is this follows up with
Turpin and it officially jumps in to the
introduction of Darkseid what this does
is it picks up with a guy who's just
referred to as boss Darkseid and the
idea that these various kids have
basically been brought under Darkseid's
control now we're not initially told how
it was that this had happened instead we
just knew these kids were being
controlled by boss Darkseid and that was
really about it
in truth this is due to the fact that
these kids are under the influence of
the anti-life equation now we'll talk
more about the anti-life equation in the
next video the long and short of it for
right now is that the anti-life equation
is basically just this equation that if
a person cracks it if they figure it out
they can dominate the wills of others
they can basically bend others to their
control with an almost absolute control
but that's basically what we're being
told here that Darkseid has managed to
figure out a way to crack the anti-life
equation the other half of this and a
story that was covered or I guess events
that were covered in DC Universe number
zero is that there was a war among the
new gods and the dark side had
quote-unquote died and truth his
spiritual essence had just been thrown
into the body of a normal person so it's
very similar to the idea of like
Ragnarok from from Marvel Comics Thor
dies all the Asgardians die and they're
reborn in human bodies and Thor has to
run around and wake them up bring about
their true selves and the difference
here is that these guys who have been
reborn on earth in human bodies when
their spiritual essences were teleported
to that location they know who they are
they're simply just biding their time
and trying to find a way to conquer the
earth and so what we end up doing here
is picking up with the Justice League
following
the death of Orion and the investigation
into how it happened now what this does
is it breathes into sharp relief
something called the Alpha lanterns
there was a story that basically dealt
with the idea of the Sinestro Corps the
you know yellow lanterns created by
thousand estro going to war against the
Green Lantern's in the Sinestro Corps
war but there was an instance where a
member of the Sinestro Corps who had
basically surrendered was killed by a
Green Lantern because of this not only
was the Green Lantern kicked out of the
Green Lantern Corps
but the guardians of the universe the
ones responsible for creating the Green
Lantern's had basically said we can no
longer allow you guys to run unchecked
instead we're gonna create something
called the Alpha lanterns and the Alpha
lanterns are going to serve the purpose
of basically policing the police now the
Alpha lanterns answered directly to the
guardians of the universe themselves and
they're effectively cyborgs but they're
the ones that carry out these internal
investigations but regardless they're
the ones conducting this and trying to
figure out what's going on because in
the middle of all this Jon Stewart's
basically attacked by someone that he
doesn't literally consider to be an
enemy only for the Alpha lanterns to
arrest Hal Jordan and the implication
here is that Hal Jordan is the one who
not only killed Orion but it also
attacked Jon Stewart and that brings in
the equation the idea that superheroes
like Hal Jordan are being dominated by
the anti-life equation now switching
back over to Batman essentially what
happens is with him having his detective
skills and basically being able to piece
things together and figure out what's
going on because of the fact that these
Alpha lanterns are part sentient because
they still have a conscious mind of
their own albeit half machine they can
still be controlled through means that
are insanely powerful and the anti-life
equation has no limit and so because
this the implication is that one of
these members of the Alpha lanterns had
basically had their well dominated by
the anti-life equation and the result is
that either they tampered with the crime
scene or something along those lines
that man seems to figure out what's
going on he's basically snatched up by a
boom tube and whisked away to apocalypse
again it's essentially this idea that
the superheroes are slowly being removed
one by one now what this does is this
brings into the equation the idea of the
Justice Society of America
now the best way to think about the JSA
is that they are basically the 1940s
superheroes from DC Comics the
jay garrick or the Green Lantern Alan
Scott so on and so forth the kicker is
this in 1956 because Barry Allen was
introduced as the new flash there was no
explanation as to where it was Jay
Garrick had gone too and so what DC did
is they came along in 1961 and they said
we'll see what had happened was when we
started publishing stories about the
flash Barry Allen
we actually switched over to stories
from a new universe we just didn't tell
you and so what they said was that every
story that ever featured the flash Barry
Allen on the Justice League or ever the
case maybe that was all in earth one all
the stories that featured like the flash
Jay Garrick things like that or earth -
the problem with this was that again
when crisis on Infinite Earths happened
DC had to find a way to basically either
justify the existence of the JSA kind of
reconciling the idea of an alternate
universe or if there were no alternate
universes kill them off entirely and
that's what they did after crisis on
Infinite Earths the JSA was gone they
basically just vanished from the face of
the earth now this lasted until 1991
with Roy Thomas I think it was and it
was basically this story that was done
in secret origins issue number 31 which
is technically volume 2 but the idea was
that DC came along and said okay so any
of these old-school superheroes they
basically have modern-day counterparts a
1940's Wonder Woman like a JSA earth to
Wonder Woman a JSA earth to Superman
things like that they're gone and what
they did is they came back and they said
okay so in this new universe continuity
after crisis on Infinite Earths
the JSA were actually just superheroes
who fought in the 1940s and 1950s and
they've long since retired and the new
superheroes took up the mantle now that
did not answer the question as to why it
was the JSA was never referenced in the
origin stories of superheroes as they
appeared in mid-1980s after crisis on
Infinite Earths happen but most fans
just kind of took it that has kind of
said whatever we just want to see the
JSA come back this lasted until 1993 and
2006 respectively 2006 was probably the
most important date just because of the
fact that with Infinite Crisis seeing
the return of the multiverse it allowed
DC to basically bring back earth - and
to say here's the newer origin of the
JSA in DC's comics it also allowed a lot
of crossing over different things like
that but if it a crisis was largely
launched because DC's continuity had
managed to just go to absolute pieces
within the 20 years of
crisis on Infinite Earths running to
infinite crisis but the overall gist of
this is that characters like the flash
Wally West whose the flash after crisis
on Infinite Earths due to barry allen
being killed and the original flash Jay
Garrick they were able to cross over
they were able to meet and it actually
resulted in some pretty cool stories but
in this instance the Wally and Jay
Garrick are just kind of going through
and you know investigating things of the
request of Batman that's really about it
any information they can find about the
death of Orion anybody who saw anything
they're basically investigating that but
in the middle of this investigation
they're suddenly met with this insanely
blinding flashing light only for us to
see the return of Barry Allen now this
is huge this was a massive moment in the
realm of DC because remember when it
came to everything from Infinite Crisis
running all the way up to 2011 with
flashpoint in the new 52 the goal was to
basically set the stage but regardless
of how they look at it ultimately it's
this idea that when it comes to Barry
Allen he had been believed to have been
dead since crisis on Infinite Earths we
covered that story already you'll find
that story down in the description when
Barry Allen sacrificed his life it
allowed DC to remove his character from
the landscape and put Wally West in his
place and we got some really cool
stories and in fact we saw a lot of the
limits being pushed when it came to the
flash wally west the kind of abilities
they had different things like that a
lot of that was pushed to the extreme
with wally west it's one of reasons why
a lot of fans loved his character
because things like the Speed Force were
created during the run of Wally West
there's just all these crazy things that
happen during those stories but the
return of Barry Allen is a big deal
because what this does is it sets the
stage for the interim flash stories
between this story final crisis and the
start of new 52 it deals with things
like the flash rebirth barry allen's new
origin by geoff johns all these
different things that took place and
sort of reshuffling his character
changing him around updating him for the
modern reader these are the kind of
things that happened and so the result
is that in this instance with regards to
the return of barry allen as is being
told by jay garrick to Barry's wife at
the time iris west what he basically
says is that when Barry showed up their
role was to actually stop the bullet to
catch the bullet that shot Orion the
problem is they could they could not
catch the bullet in time and the result
is that Oh Ryan basically died at the
same time what we also end up finding
out is that we're Barry Allen was
believed to have been dead following the
events of crisis on Infinite Earths
what he had actually done is entered the
Speed Force and from the time crisis on
Infinite Earths happened right up until
this moment he had been quite literally
outrunning death he just been running
away from death constantly odd you know
is a pretty significant deal but what
things began doing was moving in the
direction of basically taking these
major characters out of the equation
Batman who was basically teleported away
by a boom tube Hal Jordan the Green
Lantern he was taken away to be put on
trial by the guardians of the universe
for the perceived death of Orion himself
and the assault on Jon Stewart Superman
in a massive explosion that takes place
as a Daily Planet
is basically told by some unnamed person
they need to leave this universe and
they have to go somewhere else in order
to save everything
so it's this gradual staged removal of
these various characters who exist out
there within the DC superheroes
landscape so it's really interesting and
it's really kind of wild because what
ends up happening here is we actually
end up picking up with this idea of the
anti-life equation being quote-unquote
uploaded to the internet and sent out
into the digital space because what it
does is it allows Darkseid to basically
use the modern era of smartphones and
the internet to spread the anti-life
equation around the world so it's really
kind of cool because it feeds very much
into this idea of technology now in
truth when it came to Grant Morrison as
a writer this was him saying well these
are the dangers of technology you know
anybody could conquer the world humanity
is too dependent on technology but the
overall gist is that the goal of
Darkseid proves to be true he
successfully manages to conquer the
earth
the reason why we find this out is
because in their efforts to escape death
both Barry Allen and Wally West run
several weeks into the future only to
find that the world has basically been
conquered by Darkseid everybody is under
the influence of the anti-life equation
and those individuals who try to resist
Darkseid
never succeed that in the end Wonder
Woman is one of the superheroes who were
under the control of Darkseid so the
question becomes how did we get from him
releasing the anti-life equation to this
point in the future and is there any
conceivable way to stop it
okay so we are getting into Final Crisis
and the death of Batman this is the last
part of Final Crisis keep in mind this
takes place before blackest night and so
I'll try to fit it in as best I can as
far as continuity goes with the Green
Lantern playlist ah but this story's
also been referenced in like dark nights
metal and it's actually been referenced
a few times in the new 52 so I have no
idea why it took us so long to do it but
Final Crisis is basically the one of the
last major huge crossover events in DC
Comics before the new 52 in 2011 I mean
blackest night brightest day those are
huge crossovers different things like
that but the first video and I and I
highly suggest you check it out but if
you don't have the time to do it the
first video basically dealt with this
idea of something called the source
destroying the new gods originally under
Jack Kirby the source was just this
concept that was part of the fourth
world mythos with the new gods which
were totally isolated from all of DC
superheroes but because of the fact that
Jack Kirby left in the 70s and he went
back to Marvel and DC started just
gradually folding over different aspects
of the new gods Darkseid and things like
that into DC's main superhero stories
where they would crossover with Superman
and different things like that the
origins of the source or the nature it
serves has changed over the years
different riders have taken different
roles with us so there's no definitive
explanation on what it is now we can go
with the original Jack Kirby explanation
and say the source is just like this
Wellspring this massive source of energy
where all life came from but different
writers have said well the source is an
aspect of the presence which is
basically the god of the DC Universe
DC's version of the one above all from
Marvel we can take it to basically just
say the source is where all life comes
from now the idea was that the new gods
were basically going to be eliminated by
the source it was going to be DC's way
of getting rid of that whole fourth
world thing getting rid of Darkseid the
new gods all that kind of stuff the
problem was the animosity between
Darkseid and hi father who was the good
guy that led LED New Genesis because
their animosity was so extreme when they
died they continued fighting in heaven
the result was that somewhere along the
lines Darkseid basically in his forces
had gathered the anti-life equation and
the anti-life equation is a mathematical
proof that if it is shown to someone
will take away their free will the the
forces of Darkseid effectively won but
not without Darkseid being killed in the
process or at least being shot in the
process and so where he was attacked and
of course he had shot Orion different
things that happened Darkseid's body had
essentially released his essence had
basically fallen out of heaven and
through the multiverse
when Darkseid's essence crash-landed on
earth he didn't just dissipate he didn't
just die instead he took over the body
of just some crime boss somewhere and
then eventually a detective named named
Dan Turpin who was really just in the
wrong place at the wrong time was
effectively possessed by dark side and
the result is that dark sides forces who
had been reborn in new bodies began
coming together and then began
biologically modify the body of Dan
Turpin to make it suitable for the body
of darkside just because of the fact
that dark sides essence would destroy
any physical body of a normal human just
because it's so powerful basically
what's taken place now is the anti-life
equation has been released on to the
earth by the forces of Darkseid and the
result is that everything is just kind
of going to pieces it's really like a
last end in almost every conceivable way
but the story comes from two different
perspectives the first is in the modern
day when everything is beginning to fall
apart the second is about a month into
the future where everything has already
fallen apart and the idea is that
because of the fact that Barry Allen had
basically emerged from the Speed Force
having been revealed to have been alive
and been chased by the black racer who's
basically been an embodiment of death
for speedsters because it had been
chasing Barry Allen Barry Allen and
Wally West just ran as fast as they
could to get away from the black racer
and ultimately landed a month into the
future
in the modern day right now it's just
everybody doing the best they can to
stay alive as best they can almost every
single normal human who was flying on
planes or watching TV or on their phone
or whatever was blasted with the
anti-life equation when it was sent out
over every conceivable radio and
internet frequency and so something like
three billion people exist to function
under the whim of Darkseid all that's
left are whatever superheroes haven't
haven't been killed or captured and so
because of this a couple things took
place the first was that uh the Hal
Jordan the Green Lantern was basically
believed to have killed Oh Ryan you know
one of the new gods who fell to earth of
course we know that that wasn't
necessarily the case but it was believed
that that was done by Hal Jordan he was
taken from earth and he was sent to OA
to be put on trial by the guardians of
the universe Batman was just whisked
away to another realm
we didn't really know where he went to
he actually ended up going to apocalypse
where he was basically just tormented
and then Superman was whisked away to
the 31st century and so basically
anybody who could really do any real
measure of good was basically taken away
the only people that you really have
left around here are people like Green
Arrow and you have like you know Jon
Stewart one of the Green Lantern's of
Earth you've got the atom you've got
Deathstroke he's got a few people here
and there there's no Superman there's no
Batman there's no kal Jordan the Green
Lantern that's really about it things
have just really kind of gone to pot now
jumping into the future and picking up
with Barry Allen and Wally West they
actually come up with this genius plan
their idea is this Barry basically says
that the black racer will try to find
him no matter where he goes because
Barry's supposed to be dead the black
racer is an aspect of death itself the
black racer exists to take those who are
supposed to be dead and bring them to
the afterlife to send them back to their
rightful place the whole goal here is to
basically leave the black racer on a
merry chase directly to Darkseid and the
black racer will basically capture
Darkseid because he's not really
supposed to be alive Darkseid's essence
fell out of heaven for all intents and
purposes he should be dead and so he
will be captured basically taken by the
black racer and then sent to the
afterlife that's the goal of Barry Allen
and Wally West and is actually really
cool
the way they end up pulling it off but
for all the other characters that are
out there again I mean there's tie-ins
to Final Crisis the biggest problem for
the Final Crisis tie-ins is that they
don't necessarily match up with the
story that Grant Morrison wrote and so
there's actually some contradictory
stuff that goes on in there now as far
as like Oliver Queen Green Arrow as far
as a lot of those characters go
it's basically just trying to get
offworld as fast as possible or take a
refuge wherever they can I mean it's
literally just these small little areas
here and there these little bases of
operations the fortress of solitude the
Justice League Watchtower things like
that the other half of this is the
nature of time itself and space in the
sense that because of the fact that how
Jordan is basically put on trial what we
end up finding out is that one of the
Alpha lanterns has actually been
corrupted by one of the new gods now
this goes into our run on the Green
Lantern's that we do every Sunday but
the idea was that there was an event
called the Sinestro Corps war and the
Sinestro Corps war dealt with a villain
thousand Estero forming his own Lantern
Corps the yellow lanterns which went to
war with the Green Lantern's the Green
Lantern's rings were modified so they
could actually begin killing and the
problem is that one of the Green
Lantern's killed a member of the
Sinestro Corps who was actually
basically giving up who was surrendering
the result is that the guardians of the
universe said yes you can kill yellow
lanterns but only if the yellow lanterns
are trying to kill you you cannot kill a
person who's trying to surrender the
result is that that Green Lantern was
exiled from the Green Lantern Corps and
in response the Guardians made the Alpha
lanterns to police the Green Lantern
Corps the problem with this is that the
essences of the new gods transcend
anything that exists and so they can
take over any being so long as it has a
biological component and that's what the
Alpha lanterns are they're basically
cyborgs and so because of this one of
the New Gods named rainy goodness took
over one of the Alpha lanterns now
granny goodness has a great big huge
history when it comes to DC Comics but
the only thing you really need to worry
about is that she's the one who's
basically in charge of the Furies which
is basically the elite fighting force of
of Darkseid himself so again there's a
lot of history there there's a lot that
goes into it but this story is packed
enough with content as it is we're not
gonna do a great big huge thing on
granny goodness in the middle of all
this that's the long and short of it but
the idea here is that with Hal Jordan
being exonerated by the fact that he
didn't actually commit the crime that he
was framed for it allows his character
to go free but it also provides a
24-hour window in the sense that the
universe is again falling apart of the
seams and so with with Hal Jordan
basically coming back with Superman off
doing his own thing Batman off doing his
own thing and Darkseid officially risen
to power basically becoming the
character that we are the most familiar
with what this does is it shifts to a
Renee Montoya
now in the last video I think I had made
a statement that Renee Montoya his
girlfriend had died it was actually her
partner that had died so that was my
mistake but the result is that with
Renee Montoya at the current moment
she's actually going to serve as an
avatar of sorts what is up happening is
she's basically grabbed by checkmate one
of the few groups that exists around the
world that are trying to stop the entire
you know collapse of the universe
they're doing a litany of different
things they're trying to get a hold of
the spectre who's basically the
representation of God's vengeance
they're trying to reach out to other
universes I mean they're literally doing
everything they can to try to find a way
to stop this whole thing and the idea is
that Renee Montoya is basically willing
to serve as this avatar in the sense
that she is going to be a person that's
literally
going to travel through the multiverse
itself and basically just try to grab
various superheroes that can come
together in an effort to basically stop
dr. site or at the very least she's
gonna serve the point of trying to find
another inhabitable universe I think is
the initial place the way it ends up
turning out is because Darkseid ends up
getting defeated it ends up being
defeated jeans up grabbing all these
supermen together and that it goes into
the final villain of the actual Final
Crisis story but the whole idea here is
that picking back up with Hal Jordan and
Jon Stewart and Guy Gardner and a lot of
these Green Lantern's who are traveling
to earth in the intention of saving at
the skewed nature of space itself means
the closer they try to get to earth the
further away it is so they can never
actually get there you know it's like
where you're running down an endless
hallway and the door keeps moving back
with every step you take the other half
of this is that with Darkseid officially
risen this begins the process of moving
things in the direction of joining with
how we saw events turn out a month into
the future in the sense that Darkseid
basically begins gathering all the
humans around earth all three billion of
them who are under his control
and begins moving them in the direction
of capturing earth essentially now what
this does is it jumps into what
Superman's doing in the 31st century now
it comes across with him meeting with a
character named Brainiac 5 and again
Brainiac 5 has been around for a long
time the Legion of super-heroes had been
around for a very very long time now the
Legion of super-heroes dates all the way
back to adventure Comics number 247 in
1958 I think it was and they were
actually tied into Superboy now I'm
gonna give them a little more attention
here than we do a lot of the other
groups just because of the fact that
either we've covered the other groups or
because of the fact that with the Legion
of super-heroes we're gonna see them in
DC rebirth but the Legion of
super-heroes was originally introduced
really is more of like a Superboy story
than anything else back in the mid 1950s
the Superboy stories largely continued
to fall in line with the idea that it
was basically the escapades of Superman
when he was younger and the idea was
that the Legion of super-heroes was
basically the 30th to 31st century
result of modern day heroes meaning
there whether Superman or Batman or
Wonder Woman or whoever knew it when
they became superheroes on earth and
began fighting crime they set in motion
a legacy the Legion of super-heroes has
waxed and waned over the years in the
sense the rosters changed and different
characters have been introduced other
characters have gone away the stories
that involve the lead
are usually just isolated to the 30th
and 31st centuries and in fact during
final crisis there is a story called the
Legion of three worlds I think it is but
the idea is that with Superman being
brought to the 30th and 31st centuries
the Legion of super-heroes knows that
everything is going to happen but keep
in mind the existence of this future is
contingent on the success of Superman
because remember when it comes to the
actions of Darkseid when it comes to
this idea of space-time being warped
it's much like a tidal wave when a
meteor crashes on earth and tidal waves
are created they don't just suddenly
show up on the other side of the world
it takes time for them to reach the
other side of the world and that's how
this is this shockwave of space and time
being completely distorted it takes time
for those changes to reach the 30th and
31st centuries and so the idea is that
Superman being here really comes at a
crux because at this moment right now
Brainiac 5 is vanishing he's
disappearing the effects of Darkseid's
actions are beginning to reach the
future and so what Superman is basically
shown is this device that was basically
created using the concept of willpower
from the Green Lantern Corps in the
sense that the Green Lantern's tap into
the will aspect of the emotional
spectrum all that willpower is channeled
into a device which is rightfully called
the miracle machine he sees it for a few
seconds but using his x-ray vision and
just his general eyesight is basically
able to see exactly how this thing is
functioning now the whole idea is that
with everything basically crashing down
around them with everything coming to
almost a screeching halt what we end up
doing is we join up with the arrival of
Batman now Batman showing back up here
again comes out of the fact that he's
been tortured in a lot of different ways
the reason for this is because Batman
despite having no powers is probably one
of the best superheroes in DC Comics
people who hate Batman will hate me for
saying that it's the idea that he can
always use his mind to find a way to win
it might take him years to find a way
but if Batman is a piece that's left on
this quote-unquote chessboard he will
inevitably turn the tide of the game
because he'll put his mind to use and
figure out how to win the perfect
example of this is the shooting of Orion
one of the new gods who was killed
Batman puts two and two together takes
the bullet from Orion when he originally
died took the element of radion which is
harmful to new gods bound it to the
bullet and fired it into Darkseid
the craziest thing about this is that
it's a bit of a gambit it is this
instance where dark side kind of says
we're playing chicken here you can fire
this bullet but will that bullet hit me
before I hit you with the old mega beans
nothing Omega beams a dark side were
really controversial and this a little
bit of a story historically speaking the
Omega beams incinerate whoever it is
they come across for Batman who's just a
guy he should have been totally
incinerated what DC did here is they
basically said hey wouldn't you guys
want to read a story where Batman dies
but he doesn't really die he just gets
time-displaced
that's kind of what happened with this
whole particular thing it was modifying
the effects of the Omega beams just for
the sake of being able to have this part
of the story but at the time this story
happened everybody thought he died this
coincides with the arrival of Superman
because that was really the only purpose
he served in this instance it was the
Allegiant of superheroes Brainiac 5
grabbing Superman bringing him to the
31st century and saying hey look in
order for you to win you have to
memorize how this miracle machine works
if you don't everything fails and so
what he did is he memorized the miracle
machine and then was sent back now what
this does is this begins bringing in and
basically laying the groundwork for a
story called Multiversity now we're not
gonna get super in-depth into that we've
covered that already actually but it
basically gives us these different
iterations of Superman one of which is
basically a world where the superheroes
all seem to be of african-american
descent there's other ones like the zoo
crew where all the superheroes are
animals man captain carrot dude I love
Kathy Karen
captain Kara's the super bunny any
alternate version of Superman that you
could ever imagine is basically here but
there's only 52 of them because there's
only 52 Earth's in the multiverse and so
again it's kind of cool in terms of how
this happens but the idea is that they
are all basically being brought together
by Renee Montoya herself you know who's
basically going through and gathering
all these different characters what this
also does is this coincides with the
destruction of Darkseid and this happens
by way of Wally West and Barry Allen
racing in now they are basically running
at the speed of light nobody around them
is really moving everybody's just kind
of sitting there now as they begin to
get to where Darkseid is and they start
to slow down a little bit that's when we
start to get into the idea of characters
basically talking of Superman
recognizing that Barry Allen is there
his words reaching the but keep in mind
they're traveling faster than his words
can come out so basically by the time
they
to Darkseid Superman's already said his
phrase but the idea is that with a black
racer coming in it basically says I come
to all even you and so this is basically
the black racer saying everybody falls
to me everybody is going to basically
die at my hand if you are dead and you
are somehow walking around I will take
you back to the realm of the net but
with the defeat of Darkseid the question
now becomes how does everything get set
back to normal how do things get
restored to the way that they're
supposed to be and so what isn't
happening is this massive undertaking
there's a couple things that go on here
the first is that one of the things that
we hadn't quite talked about yet was a
character by the name of Shiloh Norman
now I do not know how to reconcile
Shiloh Norman and scott-free Shiloh
Norman and scott-free have both played
the role of mr. miracle at this point in
DC's continuity Shiloh Norman is mr.
miracle the idea is that he was a
protege of scott-free but I don't know
how to reconcile those two things
meaning I don't know where scot-free is
but the idea of mr. miracle is he's
basically an escape artist he is the
child of hi father from New Genesis who
was basically held captive by Darkseid
with the concept of mr. miracle
- what he basically ends up saying is
that there is a symbol that everyone who
is captured by Darkseid wears and it's
this symbol that basically ends up
saying you are allied with Darkseid but
within this alphabet is also the idea of
a symbol that will free people from the
control of Darkseid and that's exactly
what happens one of the superheroes
named Ray who's basically a character
composed of almost pure life draws this
symbol that basically fries everybody
from the control of Darkseid on earth so
it's kind of cool in terms of how that
happens but following this is this
massive undertaking by all these
different heroes and even villains lex
luthor all those characters who exists
out there trying to build this miracle
machine the problem is that time runs
out before they can pull it off and
space-time itself basically falls apart
at the seams everything falls to pieces
and so the idea of Superman is to
basically rush and finish this miracle
machine as fast as possible in order to
set everything back to the way that it's
supposed to be what we end up getting is
almost this out of place scenario we
basically end up finding out that the
evil behind all this is Mandurah now
when I say behind all this I don't mean
that manderach orchestrated everything
not at all manderach was just this evil
that was out there somewhere but
crisis serve the purpose of saying okay
so infinite crisis brought the
multiverse back how does it work
Final Crisis gave us that explanation we
talked about that before and so the idea
was that with the formation of this new
multiverse came these monitors and these
monitors were basically these beings of
an insane level of power and they were
designed for the purpose of making sure
that the universes didn't cross over so
each of these universes got its own
monitor it was basically DC's
explanation of simply sank the monitors
exist to make sure universes don't die
but it allows us to continue telling our
stories about superheroes fighting
supervillains and so the result of this
is that one of the monitors had actually
fallen and became a bad guy once he
realized that you could begin feeding
off the energy between the universes and
so this guy became man Drac who is
basically exiled and just sat outside of
the end of all things so that when the
multiverse basically collapsed and
everything died he would feed on
whatever energy was left and when the
multiverse was reborn he would retreat
and then when that multiverse ended he
was freed he would feed on what's left
so he would be this being that would
just rise to godhood slowly but steadily
and be virtually unstoppable the issue
with this is that the son of man Drac
who had basically taken over his
father's role was a character named Nick
Co 10 and Michiyo 10 story really fed
into the lead-up to Final Crisis in the
sense that the universe who was supposed
to be monitoring was totally obliterated
do a combination of the actions of
superboy-prime and then another villain
I can't member his name but the fact
remains that Nick co Thanh was basically
exiled and stripped of his powers but
with space-time fracturing and with
things just kind of out there in limbo
Nick's yotam's powers returned and so
what ended up happening is that when
Renee Montoya showed back up with all
these different versions of Superman
that this basically led into to Nick Co
tant grabbing all these other
superheroes as well he ended up seeing
him basically showing up and then you
see like the Green Lantern showing up
and you see like the zoo crew showing up
because what we're talking about is
manderach being almost God in terms of
all the power that he has he seems to be
almost unstoppable the other half of
this is that what the Green Lantern's
couldn't reach earth in the time when
Darkseid was ruling it and space-time
was being distorted because of the fact
that all of reality has completely
shattered they're protected from that
that destruction they're there but
they're basically just kind of in this
giant void and so they just try
to where it is that Superman's at being
brought there by mikio tan and everybody
else and so what is up happening is all
these forces of the Green Lantern's of
Superman and all these guys end up
destroying manderach but it's kind of
disappointing because he shows up for
like four panels and then he's dead then
he's killed and that's it that's really
all there is now a lot of that's covered
in tie-ins but remember because of the
fact that the tie ends are so
inconsistent I just kind of chose not to
cover them we can if you really really
want me to but I kind of think the story
stands on its own two feet in terms of
how it's being told but regardless
because of the fact that Nix geo tan
basically says that man Drac was a
fallin monitor and that any one of them
can end up falling down that path that
the monitors need to go away they need
to be eliminated and removed from
existence because the superheroes need
to be allowed to grow to progress now
this was basically DC simply saying okay
now that the multiverse is back and now
the superheroes are aware of them we are
going to allow the superheroes to
crossover and so getting rid of the
monitors did two birds with one stone
it allowed DC to get rid of an
unnecessary element something that
didn't really even need to be there in
the first place and then it also allowed
DC to go forward saying all these
universes are gonna start crossing over
if we choose to allow them to and the
end it didn't matter two years later DC
rebooted but the whole fact is that with
these monitors basically being viewed by
NYX Roatan as being unnecessary he
literally just starts obliterating
everything from existence all the
monitors are effectively destroyed NYX
geo tan is reborn in human form and this
allows Grant Morrison to grab his
character and send him forward into the
events of multiplicity but the last
little tail bit of the story told fans
Batman's not dead instead what ended up
happening is that when Batman was hit
with the Omega beams
he was basically sent back to the very
early days of humanity basically to the
very beginning of everything and the
result is that Grant Morrison followed
this up with a story called the return
of Bruce Wayne and it basically followed
Bruce Wayne making his way through time
back to the modern day it actually gets
to the point I think where he ends up
all the way at the very end of time and
the Justice League ends up having to
grab him and bring him back but again
the aftermath of Final Crisis saw a lot
of different things happening there was
a legion two three worlds that tied in
Superman dealing with that there are a
lot of cool things that ended up
happening you ended up getting like
Batman Incorporated and a lot of that
cool stuff but anyway guys if you want
to see that
let me know down in the comments section
let me know what you guys think if you
are new here to come this explain to
make sure you guys with the sub button
to become part of the rob Court if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and yeah I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
you